Well, you guys know we love Airbnb. I also just did a ladies' birthday trip. It was my friend's 50th birthday. All of us gals drove up the coast. It was so fun. We had the kitchen to hang out in, but then we all had our own space because, you know, we love each other, but I mean, I kind of want my own space at night. You know what I'm saying. We love the privacy. They're always in such great locations where you can really get to know the town you're in. And there's some real hidden gyms out there. These little pockets and neighbors, that you might not see if you stayed at a hotel. Listen, I could go on and on about Airbnb because I love it. It's a great way to travel with friends and family. And you know, your home might be perfect for Airbnb. If you frequently travel or have extra space, maybe you go out of town at the same time every year for a family trip. Your home could earn you money while you're away. Your home might be worth more than you think. Find out how much at Airbnb.ca.ca slash host. With Instacart, you get groceries that over-deliver. Like when your sister-in-law is coming over for appies and she's particular about cheese, Instacart's got shopper notes, so you can request Bree that's white, but more off-white. Firm, but not hard, smells earthy, but like mushroomy, not nutty. And the only thing she'll have to say is, mm. So download the app today and get $0 delivery fees on your first three orders.
你们知道我们很喜欢Airbnb。我刚参加了一次闺蜜生日旅行，是我朋友的50岁生日。我们一群姐妹开车沿着海岸线旅行，非常开心。我们有厨房可以聚在一起，但每个人也都有自己的空间，因为你知道，我们虽然相亲相爱，但晚上我还是想要自己的空间，你懂我的意思吧。我们很看重隐私。Airbnb的房源位置总是很好，让你能真正了解所在的城镇。而且还有一些真正的宝藏房源，那些你在住酒店时可能根本发现不了的小角落和邻居。听着，关于Airbnb我可以说个没完，因为我太喜欢它了。这是和朋友家人一起旅行的好方式。而且你知道，你的家可能也非常适合做Airbnb。如果你经常出差或有空余空间，或者每年固定时间去外地家庭旅行，你的家可以在你不在的时候为你赚钱。你的家可能比你想象的更值钱。去Airbnb.ca/host看看你能赚多少钱。有了Instacart，你可以买到超乎预期的杂货。比如当你的嫂子要来吃开胃菜，而她对奶酪又很挑剔时，Instacart有购物备注功能，你可以要求买那种白色的布里奶酪，但要偏灰白一点，质地要结实但不能硬，闻起来有泥土味，但要像蘑菇味，而不是坚果味。这样她唯一会说的话就是：“嗯”。所以今天就下载APP，前三单免运费。
Instacart, groceries that over deliver. Service fees, exclusions, and terms apply. Hey, everyone, happy Thanksgiving week. Yes, happy Thanksgiving week. Gobble, gobble, and welcome to your second drink of Dundermifflin Infinity, part two. So last week we covered part one of Dunder Mifflin Infinity. Now we have part two, and this is the one where Michael and Dwight drive into the lake at the end of the episode. Yep.
Instacart，超乎预期的杂货配送。服务费、排除条款和适用条件。嘿，大家好，祝大家感恩节周快乐。没错，感恩节周快乐。火鸡叫声，欢迎来到《办公室》第二季《邓德·米夫林无限》的第二部分。上周我们讲了《邓德·米夫林无限》的第一部分，现在是第二部分，也就是迈克尔和德怀特在剧集结尾把车开进湖里的那一集。没错。
Classic moment. But there was a moment that would have started this. episode that is just as shocking, at least for the universe of the office. This was deleted. It did not run, but has been added back to the superfan episode. We got a fan mail flurry about it. We sure did. Stacey T. and Liz E. said this. I recently subscribed to Peacock so I could watch the superfan episodes. The Cold Open for Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 2 opens with Toby walking into the office with his girlfriend? They walk in and see Jim and Pam at reception.
经典时刻。但这一集开头有一个时刻同样令人震惊，至少在《办公室》的世界里是这样。这一段被删减了，没有播出，但被加回了超级粉丝版剧集中。我们收到了很多关于此事的粉丝来信。确实收到了。Stacey T.和Liz E.说：我最近订阅了Peacock，这样我就可以看超级粉丝版剧集了。《邓德·米夫林无限》第二部分的冷开场是托比带着他的女朋友走进办公室？他们走进来，看到吉姆和帕姆在前台。
Toby awkwardly kisses his girlfriend for way too long and then jokes with Pam about violating his own PDA rule. Did you remember this cold open exists? You talked about an alt cold open on the podcast, but this one was not mentioned. And Katie C wrote in about this and said, ladies, you need to talk about this. Angela, what have you got for us? We definitely shot this. I even remember shooting it because the person who plays Toby's girlfriend is Paul's real-life wife, Janine.
托比尴尬地吻了他的女朋友，时间长得离谱，然后还跟帕姆开玩笑说违反了他自己制定的办公室禁止亲热（PDA）规定。你们记得这个冷开场吗？你们在播客里提到过一个备选的冷开场，但没提到这个。Katie C也写信说，女士们，你们得聊聊这个。安吉拉，你有什么要说的吗？我们确实拍了这一段。我甚至记得拍摄过程，因为扮演托比女朋友的人是保罗现实生活中的妻子珍妮。
Yes. And we all got to hang out with her for the morning. She's such a lovely person. She's really talented. And I pulled a clip. Okay, so the very long pause you're going to hear is the kissing. So sorry about that. Imagine Toby sort of really lustfully kissing his girlfriend in front of Jim and Pam at reception.
是的。那天早上我们都和她待在一起。她是个非常可爱的人，非常有才华。我剪辑了一个片段。好吧，你们听到的那段很长的停顿就是接吻声。抱歉啦。想象一下托比在吉姆和帕姆面前，在前台非常色眯眯地吻他的女朋友。
I'm a week, so... Hi, man, guys. This is my girlfriend, Amy. Hi. How you doing? Nice to meet you. This is everybody else. Hey.
我一周没见，所以……嘿，伙计们。这是我女朋友，艾米。嗨。你好吗？很高兴见到你。这是其他人。嘿。
Okay. It's the place, so thanks for the lift. Yeah, sure. I'll see you tonight, right? Absolutely. Okay. Whoa, easy tiger. I just really like you.
好了。就是这儿，谢谢你送我。好的，没问题。今晚见，对吧？当然。好的。哇，别太急。我只是真的很喜欢你。
Okay, bye you guys. Nice to meet you. Have a great date. Whoa, Toby, watch out. You're going to violate your own PDA memo. I wouldn't want to do that now, would I? Yeah, how about that? It is such a long smooch out. I know. And he's so, like, confident, which is, like, very unlike Toby. Yeah. That's pretty delicious. Oh, and here's an extra piece of trivia. If you watch the new series The Paper,
好了，再见，伙计们。很高兴见到你。祝你们约会愉快。哇，托比，小心点。你要违反你自己的PDA备忘录了。我可不想那样做，对吧？是啊，那又怎样？那个吻真的太长了。我知道。而且他表现得那么自信，这太不像托比了。是啊。这真是太有意思了。哦，还有一个额外的小花絮。如果你看新剧《纸》，
Janine is in the fourth episode and plays The Teacher. Yes. It's a great scene. We also got another letter that I thought was fun from Page S, who said, In the podcast, you mentioned Changing the Voice on the GPS, Jenna said she didn't know you could do this, so I wanted to let you know about my favorite voices. Growing up, my dad had it set to two different voices that he would switch between. His favorites were Darth Vader and Austin Powers. Darth Vader was a little harder to understand with his heavy breathing. Austin Powers was funny because when you reached your destination, he would say, groovy driving, yeah. So Jenna, when choosing your GPS voice, remember that there are more than just voices with
珍妮在第四集里扮演老师。是的。那是一场很棒的戏。我们还收到另一封我觉得很有趣的信，来自Page S，她说：在播客里，你们提到了更改GPS语音，珍娜说她不知道可以这样做，所以我想告诉你们我最喜欢的语音。我小时候，我爸爸设置了两种不同的语音，他会在两者之间切换。他最喜欢的是达斯·维达和王牌大贱谍。达斯·维达的语音因为他沉重的呼吸声有点难听懂。王牌大贱谍的语音很有趣，因为当你到达目的地时，他会说：“Groovy driving, yeah.”所以珍娜，在选择GPS语音时，记住不仅仅只有带
accents. There are also character voices. Did you know that, Angela? I did not. I did not either. Like, so what is Darth Vader? Is he like, you have reached your destination? I don't know. I mean, it's probably like, it's probably like, but like, right. Sometimes like you need it, you need the person to talk faster. So it's like, it's not like exit to San Clarito. I don't know. What? I don't know. What? I don't know. But now. I feel like I need to search this up. If you could have anybody be the voice of your GPS, who would you want? I'm trying to think.
口音的语音。还有角色语音。你知道吗，安吉拉？我不知道。我也不知道。比如，达斯·维达是怎么说的？他是说“你已经到达目的地”吗？我不知道。我的意思是，可能就像是……但就像是……对吧。有时候你需要那个人说话快一点。所以它不像“出口到圣克拉里塔”。我不知道。什么？我不知道。什么？我不知道。但现在我觉得我需要搜一下这个。如果可以选任何人作为你的GPS语音，你会选谁？我在想。
I think someone with like a really velvety voice. You know what I mean? Like a rich timber voice. Who was I just listening to who I just couldn't get enough of? It's like Barry White if he was telling me to exit the freeway. I'd probably just be like, okay, Barry. likes at the freeway. I like Jennifer Lawrence's voice. Oh, yeah? She's got like a really lovely voice to listen to. Maybe I'd like her to give me directions. These are two very distinct choices.
我觉得选一个声音非常有磁性的人。你懂我的意思吗？那种音色浑厚的声音。我刚才在听谁的声音，让我听不够来着？就像是巴里·怀特在告诉我从高速公路出口。我可能只会说，好的，巴里。喜欢高速公路出口。我喜欢詹妮弗·劳伦斯的声音。哦，是吗？她的声音听起来真的很悦耳。也许我想让她给我指路。这是两个截然不同的选择。
Well, Angela, before we go, I thought since this is Thanksgiving week, this would be a good time to share a little nugget from my digital clutter. It is the storyline for a lost Thanksgiving episode of the office. I have been so tickled about this. You mentioned it to me, and I'm like, what? Because we always say there wasn't a true Thanksgiving episode of The Office. Yeah, I have been holding on to this for so long. I found an old file with a bunch of story pitches, and there was one in the Season 3 file called Thanksgiving.
好吧，安吉拉，在我们结束之前，我想既然是感恩节周，现在是个分享我数字杂物里的一点小东西的好时机。这是《办公室》一集被遗弃的感恩节剧本大纲。我一直觉得这很有趣。你跟我提过，我当时想，什么？因为我们总是说《办公室》没有真正的感恩节剧集。是的，我保留这个很久了。我发现了一个旧文件，里面有一堆故事构思，在第三季的文件里有一个叫“感恩节”的。
It's pretty wild. Now, just remember, this is just a pitch document. It was never written, but it gives you a glimpse at what our writing. would put together. I can't wait. Are you going to read it to us? Yes. Okay. Here it is. It is Wednesday of Thanksgiving week. We start in the kitchen where Angela enters and no one will talk to her. In a talking head, Phyllis mentions that Angela is suing the company for $8.6 million because of Oscar's slap. So I guess during season three, before this episode, there was a pitch that for some reason I could not figure out why. Oscar was going to have slapped Angela. She was probably
这太疯狂了。现在，记住，这只是一个构思文档。它从未被写成剧本，但它让你瞥见了我们的编剧会写出什么样的东西。我等不及了。你要读给我们听吗？是的。好的。在这里。那是感恩节周的周三。我们从厨房开始，安吉拉进来了，没人跟她说话。在采访镜头中，菲利斯提到安吉拉因为奥斯卡的掌掴正在起诉公司，索赔860万美元。所以我猜在第三季，在这一集之前，有一个构思，出于某种我无法理解的原因，奥斯卡要扇安吉拉一巴掌。她可能
being a real bitch and he had had it. All right. So now we find out that Michael has chosen to ignore this lawsuit. It doesn't name him personally, so it's not his problem. He is also excited because he's going to spend Thanksgiving with Carol. Dwight is nervous because the Shrewt Thanksgiving is going to be at Shroot Farms this year. And moreover, he has decided to have his girlfriend meet his family. His girlfriend being Angela, although he doesn't tell everyone in the office who he means. Well, Michael hears about the shrewd gathering and the document says he shits on it. Michael says, a hundred shrewts in one barn, dork convention. So now Carol comes to see Michael at the office. She says, this is hard, but I think my kids should be with their father on Thanksgiving. So we're
真的很刻薄，而他受够了。好吧。所以现在我们发现迈克尔选择无视这场诉讼。它没有点名他个人，所以不是他的问题。他也很兴奋，因为他要和卡罗尔一起过感恩节。德怀特很紧张，因为今年的施鲁特感恩节要在施鲁特农场举行。而且，他决定让他的女朋友见他的家人。他的女朋友就是安吉拉，尽管他没有告诉办公室里的每个人他指的是谁。好吧，迈克尔听说了施鲁特的聚会，文档里说他对此嗤之以鼻。迈克尔说：“一百个施鲁特在一个谷仓里，书呆子大会。”所以现在卡罗尔来办公室找迈克尔。她说：“这很难，但我认为我的孩子们应该在感恩节和他们的父亲在一起。”所以我们要
driving to Maryland. Michael says, that's going to be awkward. Is Rick going to be okay with me being there? Carol says no. That's why you're not coming. Then in a talking head, Carol reveals that she's been reconciling with her ex and is essentially calling it off by going there. Though Michael doesn't necessarily realize the long-term implications of her actions. So now, Michael is sad because he has no place to go. Dwight's brother, a doctor from Seattle, and then in parentheses it says, who will be played by Paul Feig. Oh. Mm-hmm. Comes in to the office to visit Dwight. Dwight introduces him to Michael, and he kind of hits it off with Michael, and he invites him to the shrewp pre- Thanksgiving dinner that night, because Thanksgiving is shrews only. Michael considers.
开车去马里兰州。迈克尔说：“那会很尴尬。里克会介意我在那里吗？”卡罗尔说：“不。这就是为什么你不能去。”然后在采访镜头中，卡罗尔透露她一直在和前夫复合，去那里基本上就是为了了断。虽然迈克尔并不一定意识到她行为的长期影响。所以现在，迈克尔很难过，因为他没地方去。德怀特的兄弟，一位来自西雅图的医生，括号里写着“将由保罗·费格扮演”。哦。嗯。来到办公室拜访德怀特。德怀特把他介绍给迈克尔，他和迈克尔很投缘，他邀请迈克尔参加那天晚上的施鲁特感恩节前晚餐，因为感恩节是施鲁特家族专享的。迈克尔考虑了一下。
But Dwight is nervous about Michael coming because Angela is coming over and there's still a secret. Wait, does Dwight have to choose between Angela and Michael? Yes, at first, because Dwight says to Angela, can Michael just be there? And Angela says, I don't think it's a good idea because then Michael will know about us and it might hurt my lawsuit. So Dwight is very conflicted. But eventually, he feels like, well, my brother Paul invited Michael and I'm going to honor that. And he's also really excited for Michael to meet his dad. So Michael heads to Dwight's farm.
但德怀特很紧张迈克尔会来，因为安吉拉也要来，而且这还是个秘密。等等，德怀特必须在安吉拉和迈克尔之间做选择吗？是的，起初是这样，因为德怀特对安吉拉说：“迈克尔能在那儿吗？”安吉拉说：“我觉得这不是个好主意，因为那样迈克尔就会知道我们的事，这可能会损害我的诉讼。”所以德怀特非常纠结。但最终，他觉得：“好吧，我兄弟保罗邀请了迈克尔，我要尊重这一点。”而且他也真的很兴奋让迈克尔见他的父亲。所以迈克尔前往德怀特的农场。
He is confused when he sees Angela there, and Dwight awkwardly covers and says, oh, my girlfriend couldn't make it because she had to go to Kuwait because she's in the army, so I invited Angela, and he makes up some stupid reason that Michael believes. So they all end up having beet wine and lots of beats, and this meal is generally disgusting, is what this document says. Eventually, Dwight introduces Michael to his dad, and his dad instantly dislikes Michael because Michael made a joke about the beats. In a talking head, Dwight's dad says
当他看到安吉拉在那里时，他很困惑，德怀特尴尬地掩饰说：“哦，我女朋友来不了，因为她得去科威特，因为她在军队里，所以我邀请了安吉拉。”他编造了一个迈克尔相信的愚蠢理由。所以他们最后都喝了甜菜酒，吃了好多甜菜，文档里说这顿饭通常很恶心。最终，德怀特把迈克尔介绍给他父亲，他父亲立刻不喜欢迈克尔，因为迈克尔开了个关于甜菜的玩笑。在采访镜头中，德怀特的父亲说
Michael is frivolous and stupid and Dwight is very upset that his two father figures do not get along. So this whole Thanksgiving sort of sets up tension between Dwight and Angela, Dwight and Michael,
迈克尔轻浮又愚蠢，德怀特非常难过，因为他的两个父亲形象合不来。所以整个感恩节在德怀特和安吉拉、德怀特和迈克尔、
and Dwight and his family. So that was that storyline. And Angela and Oscar. Yes, this ongoing lawsuit. But there was also a Karen, Jim, and Pam's storyline. for this episode. Karen asked Jim if he wants to go with her to her parents' place in Stanford. She said it's totally low-key. They just watch football, no big deal. Jim says he thinks it might be too
以及德怀特和他的家人之间制造了紧张气氛。这就是那个故事线。还有安吉拉和奥斯卡。是的，这场持续的诉讼。但这一集还有一条凯伦、吉姆和帕姆的故事线。凯伦问吉姆想不想跟她一起去她在斯坦福的父母家。她说这完全很随意。他们只是看橄榄球，没什么大不了的。吉姆说他觉得可能太
soon to meet her parents. And Karen says, I totally understand. Meanwhile, Pam is in charge of taking all the canned food from the Dunder-Mifflin food drive to a homeless shelter, and she asked Jim if he wants to help her, and Jim says yes. So he says no to going to Karen's thing, but yes, to helping Pam. Well, yeah. So Pam and Jim head to the shelter. They hand out food and talk, and it's kind of like the old days.
快去见她父母了。凯伦说：“我完全理解。”与此同时，帕姆负责把邓德·米夫林食品募捐活动的所有罐头食品送到收容所，她问吉姆想不想帮她，吉姆说好。所以他拒绝了去凯伦那儿，但答应了帮帕姆。好吧，是啊。所以帕姆和吉姆去了收容所。他们分发食物并聊天，感觉就像过去一样。
But then Jim heads home early because he's decided to go to Stanford the next day to be with Karen after all. And Pam realizes it's actually not like it used to be. And that was going to be that little Thanksgiving love triangle. So there you have it.
但后来吉姆提前回家了，因为他决定第二天去斯坦福，毕竟还是要和凯伦在一起。帕姆意识到这实际上已经不像过去那样了。这就是那个感恩节三角恋。所以，就是这样。
Look at that. All that stuff. All those ideas. How good were our writers? None of that even got made. I know. What a fun, fun pitch. And I wonder how many times they had to break out and work on a pitch
看看那个。所有这些东西。所有这些想法。我们的编剧有多棒？这些甚至都没拍出来。我知道。多么有趣、有趣的构思。我不知道他们有多少次不得不拆解并研究一个构思，
and then it never even saw the light a day. I think a lot because clearly there was a whole storyline about this slap and this lawsuit that never came to fruition either. Well, that's all we got for this week. Please have a very happy Thanksgiving. And on Wednesday, we are going to be re-airing our awesome interview with Brian Cranston for the Office Lady 6.0 episode. And then we'll be back next week.
然后它甚至从未见天日。我想很多，因为显然有一个关于这个掌掴和诉讼的完整故事线，也从未实现。好吧，这就是我们这周的所有内容。祝大家感恩节快乐。周三，我们将重播我们对布莱恩·科兰斯顿的精彩采访，作为《办公室女士》6.0集。然后我们下周会回来，
with all new episodes. And now here is your second drink of Dunder Mifflin Infinity, Part 2. I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office
带来全新的剧集。现在是你们的《邓德·米夫林无限》第二部分。我是詹娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金赛。我们一起出演了《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在做终极《办公室》
Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week, we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're the Office, ladies. Happy New Year.
重温播客，专为你准备。每周，我们将剖析《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》。新年快乐。
Man, oh man, new year. I'm in a new size pants. I really am. I went up a whole pants size. I made some New Year's resolutions, Jenna, and one of them is I'm going to move more. I'm going to keep it really simple. I'm just going to move more. You know, I did that, Ang, because I felt really creaky when I would wake up in the morning, and I didn't like it. I felt like the age in my bones, you know, and I was like, you know, keep it in motion. Yeah. It's a good thing. Yeah. I'm just going to go on more walks. This is my big New Year's resolution.
天哪，天哪，新年。我穿上了新尺码的裤子。真的。我裤子尺码大了一号。我做了一些新年决心，詹娜，其中之一就是我要多运动。我会保持非常简单。我只是要多运动。你知道，我做到了，安吉，因为我早上醒来时感觉骨头很响，我不喜欢那样。我觉得我的骨头老了，你知道，我就想，保持运动。是的。这是件好事。是的。我只是要多散步。这是我最大的新年决心。
More walking. I think that's good. Movement, fresh air. It's good for your health in so many ways. Yeah. I'm for this. I can't make. my resolution's too complicated or it won't happen. So I'm keeping it real simple. Make attainable
多走路。我觉得这很好。运动，新鲜空气。这对你的健康有很多好处。是的。我支持这个。我不能让我的决心太复杂，否则就不会实现。所以我保持非常简单。制定可实现的目标。
goals. This is amazing. I'm going to walk with you. And we're excited to share with you now, Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 2. Yeah. And I have to say it's worth the wait because Michael's going to drive his car into a lake this week. Oh, and we have lots to say about it. We do. Let's get started. Let's do it. Dunder Mifflin Infinity Part 2, Season 4, Episode 4, written by Mike Scher and directed by Craig Zisk. Here is a summary. Michael tries to show up Ryan and his emphasis on technology by winning back clients with old-fashioned customer service and elaborate gift baskets. Along the way, he drives into a lake after misinterpreting the directions from his GPS. Also in this episode, Ryan asked Pam to design
这太棒了。我要和你一起走。我们现在很高兴与你们分享《邓德·米夫林无限》第二部分。是的。我不得不说这值得等待，因为迈克尔这周要把他的车开进湖里。哦，我们有很多话要说。我们确实有。让我们开始吧。开始吧。《邓德·米夫林无限》第二部分，第四季第四集，由迈克·谢尔编剧，克雷格·齐斯克执导。这是一个摘要。迈克尔试图通过老式的客户服务和精心制作的礼品篮赢回客户，以展示瑞安对技术的重视。一路上，他在误解了GPS的指示后，把车开进了一个湖里。在这一集中，瑞安还让帕姆为《邓德·米夫林无限》设计
some logos for Dunder Mifflin Infinity, and then he asks her out, and Angela makes it clear to Dwight that they are done. Yeah, she is not forgiving him. Well, gang, since we did fast facts on the first half of this episode, and since it is a new year, we thought we should pay a visit to our mailbag and answer some questions. Yes, it's time to talk to you guys. Well, our first letter came from Jesse S. And she said, hi, I am a hard of hearing person who loves to listen to the podcast, but I do miss some things as I rely on lip reading a lot. I am wondering if transcribing the podcast is an option for other deaf and hard of hearing who are fans of the show and would love to be able to interact with the podcast. Well, guys, we do have a transcription for every single
一些标志，然后他约她出去，安吉拉向德怀特明确表示他们结束了。是的，她没有原谅他。好吧，伙计们，既然我们已经完成了这一集前半部分的快速事实，而且既然是新年，我们想我们应该看看我们的邮件，回答一些问题。是的，是时候和你们聊聊了。好吧，我们的第一封信来自杰西·S。她说：嗨，我是一个听力障碍者，喜欢听这个播客，但我确实错过了一些东西，因为我非常依赖读唇语。我想知道为其他也是该剧粉丝且希望能够与播客互动的失聪和听力障碍者提供播客转录是否是一个选择。好吧，伙计们，我们确实有每一集的转录，
episode going back to the pilot, and you can find it on officeladys.com. If you go to the episodes and scroll down, there's a little button for transcript. Yes, you go past the sort of summary of the episode, and it's right there, and you can click on it and read the whole thing. This is kind of personal to me, Jesse, because my sister, Emily, wears hearing aids, and she also relies on lip reading. And so I know that sometimes being able to both listen and read along is really helpful for her. And also, like when I go to her house, she always has the closed caption on her TV. So we definitely, definitely want the podcast to be accessible to everyone. So guys, if there's any other ways we can make it more accessible, let us know.
一直追溯到试播集，你可以在officeladys.com上找到它。如果你进入剧集并向下滚动，有一个转录的小按钮。是的，你越过剧集的摘要，它就在那里，你可以点击它并阅读全文。这对我很私人，杰西，因为我的妹妹艾米戴助听器，她也依赖读唇语。所以我知道有时能够同时听和读对她非常有帮助。而且，就像我去她家时，她总是打开电视的隐藏字幕。所以我们绝对、绝对希望播客对每个人都是无障碍的。所以伙计们，如果还有其他我们可以让它更无障碍的方法，请告诉我们。
Yes. And in the meantime, go to OfficeLadies.com and go to each episode and scroll down and their transcript is right there. and we have a team here at Earwolf that helps us with that, and we so appreciate it. All right. Well, our next question, Jenna, comes from Julie Weiss, and she says, I have a question about kissing the other actors. How do you prep for kissing someone that you were friends with, but not romantically involved with? Was it ever awkward?
是的。同时，去OfficeLadies.com，进入每一集并向下滚动，转录就在那里。我们在Earwolf有一个团队帮助我们完成这项工作，我们非常感谢。好吧，下一个问题，詹娜，来自朱莉·韦斯，她说：我有一个关于亲吻其他演员的问题。你如何准备亲吻一个你是朋友但没有恋爱关系的人？这尴尬吗？
Oh, Julie. Julie, it's always awkward. It's always awkward. And thank goodness over the years, though, you do become such good friends that it's just like, okay, well, we'll just do this really quickly. But something that made it difficult for me, which maybe you wouldn't think about, is that I often had to kiss Rain Wilson. And for whatever reason, he was usually eating something disgusting right beforehand. And I'd be like, Rain, dang it. Do you have to eat a tuna fish sandwich right before we're supposed to kiss?
哦，朱莉。朱莉，这总是很尴尬。这总是很尴尬。但谢天谢地，多年来，你们确实成为了很好的朋友，所以就像是，好吧，我们很快就会做完。但有一件事让我觉得困难，你可能不会想到，那就是我经常不得不亲吻雷恩·威尔逊。不管什么原因，他通常在亲吻前都在吃一些恶心的东西。我会说，雷恩，该死。我们在亲吻前一定要吃金枪鱼三明治吗？
Come on. Yeah, I remember he would always be like downing a cup of coffee and an everything bagel. Yes. And he'd be like, I'm ready for my kissing scene. And you would be like, rain, a mint. Can you do something? Anything at this point, just not the everything bagel, you know? My God.
拜托。是啊，我记得他总是喝下一杯咖啡和一个全麦贝果。是的。他会说，我准备好拍吻戏了。你会说，雷恩，薄荷糖。你能做点什么吗？这时候什么都行，只要不是全麦贝果，你知道吗？天哪。
Well, at least for me, John was always very conscientious. He would have a mint or some gum. A mint. Rain Wilson, a mint. We were very breath-aware. Rain, not so much. Also, Julie, we didn't do the big open-mouth stuff that maybe you see in movies and whatnot. This was like television, comedy kissing is very different than like a dramatic movie, make-out, you know, it's, your lips are kind of just together.
好吧，至少对我来说，约翰总是很自觉。他会吃薄荷糖或口香糖。薄荷糖。雷恩·威尔逊，薄荷糖。我们非常注意口气。雷恩，没那么注意。另外，朱莉，我们没有做你在电影里可能看到的那些大张嘴的亲吻。这是电视，喜剧亲吻和戏剧电影里的那种亲吻非常不同，你知道，你的嘴唇基本上只是贴在一起。
You know, you kind of fake it. You makey kiss, faky bag. Well, our next question comes from Jessica Willis. I've always been curious how much ADR did you have to typically do for your episodes. I've noticed that in some episodes, you see characters remove a mic pack and the audio goes black. It's such a real cool detail and a reference to the documentary. So how much original audio did you use and how much was re-recorded after filming? Well, lady, my memory is we did not do a lot of ADR.
你知道，你有点假装。假装亲吻，假装。好吧，下一个问题来自杰西卡·威利斯。我一直很好奇你们通常需要为剧集做多少ADR（后期配音）。我注意到在一些剧集中，你看到角色摘下麦克风包，音频就黑了。这是一个非常酷的细节，是对纪录片的参考。那么你们用了多少原始音频，有多少是在拍摄后重新录制的？好吧，女士，我的记忆是我们没有做很多ADR。
I mean, I have one memory of the whole nine years of going in to do it. Yeah. In the entire nine years, I only recorded one line that they had to dub in later, one in nine years. And I thought that's how it worked. Yeah. And when I went on other jobs, part of your job is you go in a studio every week and you dub lines that got missed or that maybe a plane flew over your head or there was a sound problem and they dump it in. And I'd spend maybe 30 minutes an hour just doing that on other shows. But on our show, we did not.
我的意思是，九年里我只记得有一次进去做这个。是的。在整整九年里，我只录了一句他们后来必须配音的台词，九年里只有一句。我以为这就是工作方式。是的。当我去做其他工作时，你每周都要去工作室，配上错过的台词，或者可能有一架飞机飞过你的头顶，或者有声音问题，他们会把它补进去。在其他节目中，我可能要花30分钟到一个小时做这个。但在我们的节目中，我们没有。
And why is that, Jenna? Because same, all the other projects I've gone on, you have like an ADR day where you go in. But on the office, I only did ADR once and it was for the finale. And I got to see footage of the finale before it aired before anyone saw it because I went in and had to loop one line. And it was because we were outside. And, you know, we had that storm coming in. and they just needed me to loop a line. And I even took a picture in the ADR booth because I'd never been in there.
为什么会这样，詹娜？因为一样，我参加的所有其他项目，你都有一个ADR日，你要进去。但在《办公室》，我只做过一次ADR，那是为了大结局。在大结局播出前，在任何人看到之前，我就看到了大结局的片段，因为我进去必须补录一句台词。那是因为我们在外面。而且，你知道，那场风暴来了。他们只是需要我补录一句台词。我甚至在ADR录音棚里拍了一张照片，因为我从来没去过那里。
You know, first of all, our sound engineers were Emmy Award winning. They won Emmys for their sound design on our show. They're just amazing. But they also had a mic pack on every single actor. We had two boom operators in the room. And they hid microphones throughout the office. I had one at reception. Oh, yeah.
你知道，首先，我们的音响工程师是艾美奖得主。他们因我们节目中的声音设计赢得了艾美奖。他们太棒了。但他们还在每个演员身上都装了麦克风包。我们在房间里有两个吊杆操作员。他们把麦克风藏在办公室各处。我在前台有一个。哦，是的。
We had a microphone in the account. counting pod. And they put it next to Oscar's phone. So it would sort of pick up the three of us, you know? But I also remember I would often see our boom operators and camera operators having little powwows because they would have to choreograph the boom swing with the camera swing so that they could pick up the sound. And it was this crafted dance that they did. And it's really amazing. And I'm actually glad that Jessica wrote in because it gives us a chance to really shout out our sound department, which was incredible. Our main guys that were with us on the stage were Ben Patrick. Yep. He was our main like production sound mixer sound editor. And we had our two boom
我们在会计区有一个麦克风。他们把它放在奥斯卡的电话旁边。所以它会捕捉到我们三个人的声音，你知道吗？但我还记得我经常看到我们的吊杆操作员和摄像师进行小会议，因为他们必须编排吊杆的摆动和摄像机的摆动，这样他们才能捕捉到声音。这是他们精心制作的舞蹈。这真的很神奇。我其实很高兴杰西卡写信来，因为这给了我们一个机会真正向我们的音响部门致敬，他们太不可思议了。我们在现场的主要人员是本·帕特里克。是的。他是我们主要的制作混音师和声音编辑。我们有两个吊杆
operators, Nick Carbone. Don't get carboned. Don't get carboned. And Brian Whittle, Brian Whittle would be the inspiration for the boom operator that we see later in the season. In the story, yeah. But then we also had like a mixing department and we had other boom operators and people that would rotate in. We just had a really amazing sound team. Yeah, they were great. Well, we have one more question. This one is from Alicia W.
操作员，尼克·卡伯恩。别被卡伯恩了。别被卡伯恩了。还有布莱恩·惠特尔，布莱恩·惠特尔将成为我们在本季晚些时候看到的吊杆操作员的灵感来源。在故事里，是的。但我们也有混音部门，还有其他吊杆操作员和轮换进来的人。我们有一个非常棒的音响团队。是的，他们很棒。好吧，我们还有一个问题。这个来自艾丽西亚·W。
She asked, in the talking heads where the camera is facing into the office, Stanley is almost always in the background. Would Leslie David Baker have to stay in the background the whole time they filmed talking heads? Or was that background edited in? Oh, Alicia. He had to sit there. Yes. For nine years.
她问，在摄像机对着办公室的采访镜头中，斯坦利几乎总是出现在背景里。莱斯利·大卫·贝克在他们拍摄采访镜头时必须一直待在背景里吗？还是那个背景是后期剪辑进去的？哦，艾丽西亚。他必须坐在那里。是的。九年了。
Poor Leslie David Baker. He was always in the background. He was always there. You could see him at his desk. And he was such a trooper. When people had talking heads, when we had a long day of them, he'd sit there. Yep. And sometimes Phyllis would have.
可怜的莱斯利·大卫·贝克。他总是在背景里。他总是在那里。你可以看到他在他的办公桌前。他真是个硬汉。当人们有采访镜头时，当我们有漫长的一天拍摄时，他会坐在那里。是的。有时菲利斯也会
have to sit there and sometimes creed as well. Yes. And early on, they would have people there designated to cross. Like you might see someone like cross to the kitchen or cross back. We abandoned that after a couple of seasons. I think if you look at early season talking heads, you see crosses in the background. And then at a certain point, people are like, I think, I'm thinking no. I think I'm not going to go to the kitchen and back to get a cup of coffee for two.
不得不坐在那里，有时克里德也是。是的。在早期，他们会指定人从那里穿过。就像你可能会看到有人穿过厨房或走回来。我们在几季之后就放弃了这一点。我想如果你看早期的采访镜头，你会看到背景里有人穿过。然后在某个时候，人们会想，我想，我在想不。我想我不会为了两小时去厨房再回来喝杯咖啡。
hours. Yeah. Also, I think they were a little distracting because I know I did a cross one time and they had me cross really close to the conference room, that cabinet that was there. And then they were like, eh, no. And then they had me cross way in the back. But I think ultimately they were just like, okay, no, no crossing. Well, also, if you wanted to improv, it would throw off the timing of the cross. Yeah. And so you would, when you went into editing, it did not work for crosses. It just worked to have poor Leslie at his desk as a constant. Leslie, and then you Creed. I think Creed would be the number two runner up for that. I think so too. And then before we go to break, we just got a really nice comment and it made us happy so we thought we'd share it. It is from
是的。另外，我觉得他们有点分散注意力，因为我知道我有一次穿过，他们让我穿过离会议室很近的地方，就是那个柜子所在的地方。然后他们说，呃，不。然后他们让我从后面穿过。但我认为最终他们只是说，好吧，不，不穿过。好吧，另外，如果你想即兴表演，它会打乱穿过的时机。是的。所以当你进入剪辑时，穿过就不起作用了。让可怜的莱斯利坐在他的办公桌前作为一个常数才起作用。莱斯利，然后是克里德。我觉得克里德会是第二名。我也这么认为。在我们休息之前，我们刚收到一个非常好的评论，它让我们很高兴，所以我们想分享一下。它来自
Cecilia B. And she says, ladies, I have to tell you, you two are amazing. Thank you, Cecilia. I finally got the courage to ask for our changes at work. And all I kept hearing was both of you ladies in my head saying, just go for it. Ask for what you want. And I'm so happy that I listen to you, ladies. Now I get to have an extra hour with my daughters. I'm a single mom, and every second with them counts. Thank you, ladies. Well, that makes me so happy.
塞西莉亚·B。她说，女士们，我必须告诉你们，你们两个太棒了。谢谢你，塞西莉亚。我终于有勇气要求我们在工作中做出改变。我脑子里一直听到你们两位女士说，去争取吧。要求你想要的。我很高兴我听了你们的话，女士们。现在我可以和我的女儿们多待一个小时了。我是一个单亲妈妈，和她们在一起的每一秒都很重要。谢谢你们，女士们。好吧，这让我太高兴了。
Aw. Well, Cecilia, that makes us so happy to hear. And what? Oh, Sam is waving at me, Jenna. Before we go to break, Sam, what do you got? I wanted to let you guys know on the Office Ladies' podcast fan page. I know you guys aren't on Facebook. We've heard of this, though, Jenna.
噢。好吧，塞西莉亚，听到这个我们太高兴了。什么？哦，萨姆在向我挥手，詹娜。在我们休息之前，萨姆，你有什么？我想让你们知道在《办公室女士》播客粉丝页面上。我知道你们不在Facebook上。但我们听说过这个，詹娜。
Yes. People have shared with us. So hi, you guys. Hello. There is a whole thread of people agreeing with Cecilia that had similar experiences. There's a woman named Naomi Timmer, who went in and told her boss she deserved more money after listening to that episode and got a raise. And then there's a whole thread of people underneath it who'd realize that they had been operating the same way negotiating themselves down before they went in the interview who are not going to do it anymore. Oh my gosh. That is so great. I love that you're all sharing about. it too. I love that so much. It's awesome. Well, I feel like I should give a shout out to the person who gave me this piece of advice. His name is Jeff Ulrich. And ever since he told me this, it has really resonated with me. I've been like, oh my gosh, I've been negotiating with myself for less than I deserve my whole life. So this is a new piece of advice to me too. So we're all doing this together,
是的。人们和我们分享过。所以嗨，你们好。你好。有一个完整的帖子，人们同意塞西莉亚的观点，他们有类似的经历。有一个叫娜奥米·蒂默的女人，她在听了那一集后进去告诉她的老板她值得更多的钱，并得到了加薪。然后下面有一整串人意识到他们一直以同样的方式运作，在面试前就自己压低了价格，他们再也不会那样做了。天哪。那太棒了。我喜欢你们都在分享。我太喜欢这个了。这太棒了。好吧，我觉得我应该向给我这个建议的人致敬。他的名字叫杰夫·乌尔里希。自从他告诉我这个，它真的引起了我的共鸣。我一直在想，天哪，我一生都在和自己谈判，得到的比我应得的少。所以这对我也算是一个新的建议。所以我们都在一起做这件事，
folks. Yes. And Sam, thanks for sharing that. And I've been hearing about this Facebook fan group of office ladies. And I just, I just love the community. You guys are building there. And if I wasn't 100 years old, I don't know how to navigate Facebook. Guys, I tried. It's too. I don't understand it. But it's too many things too. I have to have just the one. That's the space I'm in. I know. I know. Like between kids and life, I'm like, I can, I can look at one thing. But I will say someone did point this Facebook page out to us because the community that is being built there is really supportive, really encouraging, really positive. And I feel like especially now, what a great community to have built. It's really cool.
伙计们。是的。萨姆，谢谢你的分享。我一直听说这个Facebook的《办公室女士》粉丝群。我只是，我只是喜欢你们在那里建立的社区。如果我不是100岁，我不知道如何浏览Facebook。伙计们，我试过了。太……我不明白。但东西太多了。我必须只有一个。这就是我所处的空间。我知道。我知道。就像在孩子和生活之间，我想，我可以，我可以看一件事。但我会说有人确实向我们指出了这个Facebook页面，因为那里建立的社区真的很有支持性，很鼓励人，真的很积极。我觉得尤其是现在，建立这样一个社区真是太好了。这真的很酷。
Yeah, it means a lot to us. And Sam, you'll have to continue to share with us. Sounds good. Okay. Yeah. Because if you peek in on the group, will you say what it's called again, Sam? It is simply the Office Ladies podcast fan page. Oh, awesome.
是的，这对我们意义重大。萨姆，你得继续和我们分享。听起来不错。好的。是的。因为如果你窥探那个群组，你能再说一遍它叫什么吗，萨姆？它简单地叫《办公室女士》播客粉丝页面。哦，太棒了。
Well, we should go to break and get back and get into this episode. Let's do it. Do you know what you do not want, especially at the holidays? Tell me. A stinky house. No, I don't want a stinky house. People are coming over. Yeah, but also, sometimes you don't want a candle.
好吧，我们应该休息一下，回来进入这一集。开始吧。你知道你不需要什么，特别是在假期？告诉我。一个臭房子。不，我不想要一个臭房子。人们要过来。是的，但有时你也不想要蜡烛。
I have something for you. Okay. It's called pura, and they are reimagining the future of fragrance. It is a smart home. fragrance brand. Okay. And they're little diffusers. So they put out like a little poof of scent. Well, that sounds lovely. And it's not just for your house, though. You can put it in your car. It makes a great gift. Right now they have up to 30% off their website from November 20th to the 30th. It is their biggest sale of the year, and it's only for a limited time.
我有个东西给你。好的。它叫pura，他们正在重新构想香氛的未来。这是一个智能家居香氛品牌。好的。它们是小扩散器。所以它们会散发出一点点香味。嗯，听起来很可爱。而且它不仅仅是为了你的房子。你可以把它放在车里。它是一个很棒的礼物。现在他们在11月20日到30日期间网站上有高达30%的折扣。这是他们一年中最大的促销，而且只在有限的时间内。
So you can get all of their premium, long-lasting single fragrances. You could even do a curated gift set for someone on your holiday list. So head to pura.com to unwrap the savings and upgrade your space just in time for the holidays. Spend less time shopping, more time enjoying. Get set for a gifting season only at pura.com. The holidays are here and that means it's the most wonderful time of the year to save with Rackaton. Use Racketon to stack cashback at your favorite stores on top of holiday sales.
所以你可以买到他们所有的优质、持久的单一香氛。你甚至可以为你的节日名单上的人做一个精选礼品套装。所以前往pura.com拆开优惠，并在假期及时升级你的空间。少花时间购物，多花时间享受。只在pura.com为送礼季节做好准备。假期到了，这意味着这是用Rakuten节省开支的一年中最美好的时光。使用Rakuten在假期销售之上，在你最喜欢的商店叠加现金返还。
That's savings on savings. With Racketon, you can get cash back. on gifts for everyone on your list, from toys for the kids, to kitchen gear, for the person who loves to cook, to electronics for everyone. You can even save on something for yourself. Just shop the stores you love, and cashback is automatically added to your account, and you can choose to get paid via Interacte Transfer, PayPal, or check. Join for free today and get a new member bonus after minimum qualifying purchases. Just go to racketon.ca. Download the app or install the browser extension. It's R-A-K-U-T-E-N.
那是节省之上的节省。有了Rakuten，你可以获得现金返还。为你名单上的每个人购买礼物，从给孩子们的玩具，到给喜欢做饭的人的厨房装备，再到给每个人的电子产品。你甚至可以为自己节省一些东西。只需在你喜欢的商店购物，现金返还就会自动添加到你的账户中，你可以选择通过Interacte转账、PayPal或支票获得付款。今天免费加入，并在最低合格购买后获得新会员奖金。只需前往racketon.ca。下载APP或安装浏览器扩展。它是R-A-K-U-T-E-N。
Terms and conditions apply. All right, now we're in Dundermifflin Infinity Part 2. It starts with a scene in the conference room, right? Michael is showing them all the gift baskets, but Jenna, there was a deleted scene that would have started this part of the episode. What was it? I loved it. I found it fascinating.
条款和条件适用。好吧，现在我们在《邓德·米夫林无限》第二部分。它以会议室里的一个场景开始，对吧？迈克尔正在向他们展示所有的礼品篮，但詹娜，有一个被删减的场景本可以开始这一部分的剧集。是什么？我喜欢它。我觉得它很迷人。
And it's an alt. They ultimately end up providing this information. with Dwight later, but there was a scene with Michael by himself, and it's the start of his day, and he's driving into work. He's doing one of those driving, talking heads that Michael does, right? Oh, well, the last time he did that, it was very dangerous. I know, I know. He hit an employee. He did. So it's the same thing. He's driving into work, and he's sort of showing off his rental car. It looks like a Ford Taurus. I see Ford. I think Taurus. I don't know, guys. Correct me if I'm wrong on that. But we learn the whole backstory, why he's not driving the seabring.
这是一个备选。他们最终在后面和德怀特一起提供了这些信息，但有一个迈克尔独自一人的场景，那是他一天的开始，他正开车去上班。他正在做迈克尔做的那些开车、采访镜头，对吧？哦，好吧，上次他那样做时，非常危险。我知道，我知道。他撞了一个员工。他撞了。所以是一样的。他正开车去上班，他有点在炫耀他的租车。看起来像一辆福特金牛座。我看到福特。我想金牛座。我不知道，伙计们。如果我错了，请纠正我。但我们了解了整个背景故事，为什么他没开赛百灵。
Michael said he had to get a rental car because his seabring is in the body shop because Meredith left a big dent in the hood. And then he said, but listen, this rental has navigation. And Michael calls it his invisible driving companion. Aw. And he goes, but, you know, listen, it is really amazing. and it's like a computerized map in your car. And he goes on to say that he loves its voice, that he finds it so soothing.
迈克尔说他不得不租一辆车，因为他的赛百灵在车身修理厂，因为梅雷迪思在引擎盖上留下了一个大凹痕。然后他说，但听着，这辆租来的车有导航。迈克尔称它为他隐形的驾驶伴侣。噢。他说，但，你知道，听着，它真的很神奇。它就像你车里的电脑地图。他继续说他喜欢它的声音，他觉得它非常舒缓。
It's like taking a warm bath. And while he's saying how much he loves the voice, Jan calls. And this is what we hear. Sam, will you play that? Oh, oh, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on. Ah, it is my lady love. Smelo.
就像洗个热水澡。当他说他有多喜欢这个声音时，简打来了电话。这就是我们听到的。萨姆，你能播放那个吗？哦，哦，等等，等等，等等，等等。啊，是我的爱人。斯梅洛。
Where the fuck are my grape nuts? I don't... I just want to know, did you eat my grape nuts? No, I hate those things. Pro-out, Michael. I love... Not a morning person. Oh, no.
我的葡萄干麦片在哪儿？我不知道……我只是想知道，你吃我的葡萄干麦片了吗？不，我讨厌那些东西。迈克尔，别这样。我爱……不是个早起的人。哦，不。
Oh, my God. And then after that, he sits in the car in silence, and he just hits the navigation button, so it just keeps talking to him. You have arrived. You have... It's like, he just needs something soothing. Oh, lady. Oh, wow. Wow. Just a window into his life with Jan. And maybe a little bit of the reason why he trusts the navigation so much, because it's just this soothing, invisible driving companion. Yeah, I get that.
哦，天哪。在那之后，他沉默地坐在车里，他只是按了导航按钮，所以它一直对他说话。你已经到达。你已经……就像是，他只是需要一些舒缓的东西。哦，女士。哦，哇。哇。只是他与简生活的一扇窗户。也许还有一点他如此信任导航的原因，因为它只是这个舒缓的、隐形的驾驶伴侣。是的，我明白了。
So, yes, this episode actually does start with the conference room. Jenna, did you see the spread on that table? It was incredible. I remember it from shooting. They had excellent, excellent little snacks and treats. Excellent. In fact, Michael says that he got the finest gourmet items that Scranton has to offer. How much did this all cost? I love every time you ask that question, you are personally fascinated by how Michael funds all of his extracurriculars. And it's such a good question to ask. This is where Angela Martin, the accountant character, bleeds into your real personality. It is because let me tell you, those baskets were not cheap. Look at those.
所以，是的，这一集确实以会议室开始。詹娜，你看到桌子上的那些东西了吗？太不可思议了。我从拍摄时就记得它。他们有非常、非常好的小零食和点心。非常好。事实上，迈克尔说他得到了斯克兰顿所能提供的最好的美食。这一切花了多少钱？我喜欢你每次问那个问题，你个人对迈克尔如何资助他所有的课外活动很着迷。这是一个很好的问题。这就是安吉拉·马丁，那个会计角色，渗透到你真实性格的地方。确实是因为让我告诉你，那些篮子可不便宜。看看那些。
I love baskets. My husband says my nickname should be baskets. I have a basket problem. If I see a basket, I'm going to buy it. And I'm telling you, those baskets are primo baskets. Angela, I know that you recently did a huge clean out of your garage. I did. Will you share?
我喜欢篮子。我丈夫说我的绰号应该叫“篮子”。我有篮子成瘾症。如果我看到一个篮子，我一定会买下它。我跟你说，那些篮子可是极品。安吉拉，我知道你最近把车库彻底清理了一遍。是的。你能和我们分享一下吗？
with us, how many baskets were in the garage? 37. Yeah, 37. How many did you keep? 12. I picked my 12 favorite, and let me tell you, it was hard for me to let go. I donated them to a church in our neighborhood that does outreach, and I was very happy that they got my baskets, but it was hard to say goodbye. I felt like when you were leaving me messages about this, I was really proud of you for this progress.
车库里有多少个篮子？37个。对，37个。你留下了多少个？12个。我挑出了我最喜欢的12个，我得说，要我放弃其他的真的很难。我把它们捐给了社区里一家做外展服务的教堂，我很高兴它们有了新去处，但要告别它们还是很难。我觉得当你给我发这些信息时，我真的为你取得的进步感到骄傲。
Thank you. With your basket issue. Thank you. Yeah. That's not counting how many baskets I have inside the house. Oh, no. That I'm using, though. Like, I have a basket, Jenna, by the fireplace that I roll up and I put blankets in.
谢谢。关于你的篮子问题。谢谢。是的。那还没算上我屋子里有多少个篮子呢。哦，不。不过那些我都在用。比如，珍娜，我在壁炉旁放了一个篮子，用来卷放毯子。
And then I have a basket in my bedroom that I roll up and put blankets in. Listen, I have a lot of blankets around my house because I have a basket. My husband is a giant mountain man, and I'm always freezing. He runs hot. I have baskets of blankets stashed all around. Okay. That is the title of your autobiography, Baskets of Blanket by Angela Kinsey. With a side of donuts and a glass of wine.
然后我在卧室里也放了一个篮子，用来卷放毯子。听着，我家里有很多毯子，因为我有篮子。我丈夫是个像山一样高大的男人，而我总是觉得冷。他却很怕热。我到处都藏着装满毯子的篮子。好吧。这就是你的自传标题了，《安吉拉·金赛的毯子篮》。配上一份甜甜圈和一杯红酒。
It's a very long title. One million copies already sold. Yep. All right. Well, Michael has this talking head where he explains what these. baskets are all about. He says, you know, Ryan thinks everything is about emails and IMs. It's all about technology, but he's forgetting about the original instant message, which is a letter attached to a basket of food. Yeah, that's the original I am, you guys, in case you were wondering. Well, I guess
这标题太长了。已经卖出一百万册了。没错。好了。迈克尔有个采访片段，他解释了这些篮子的意义。他说，你知道，瑞安认为一切都离不开电子邮件和即时通讯。一切都是科技，但他忘了最初的即时通讯，那就是附在食物篮上的一封信。是的，伙计们，如果你好奇的话，那就是最初的即时通讯。好吧，我想
speaking of the cost of these baskets, Dwight is going to turn in receipts for the cost of these gift baskets to Angela. Yeah, who is very, very icy toward him. Yeah. And before we get into the scene, Jenna, we've brought this up before, but for any of you that missed it, 22 minutes, 53 seconds, you can clearly see on the message board under Thus, T-H-U-S, Thus, the following caption. In case you haven't noticed, there's a lot of colorful Huey on this board. Well, it's interesting you mention that, Angela, because we had several people write in about this white board behind you. Katie E., Julie Bird, and Christopher Neville all said that there's even more stuff on the board now. For example, there is an anger management appreciation day on Tuesday the 23rd.
说到这些篮子的成本，德怀特要向安吉拉提交这些礼品篮的收据。是的，她对他非常非常冷淡。是的。在进入那个场景之前，珍娜，我们之前提过，但如果有人错过了，在22分53秒，你可以清楚地看到留言板上“Thus”（因此）这个词下面有以下说明。如果你还没注意到，这个板子上有很多彩色的“Huey”。好吧，安吉拉，你提到这个很有趣，因为有几个人写信问起你身后这个白板。凯蒂·E、朱莉·伯德和克里斯托弗·内维尔都说现在板子上的东西更多了。例如，周二23号有“情绪管理感谢日”。
On the 8th, there is an accounting department meeting, and it specifies be prepared to show your work. And on the 10th, it says flex times, which interestingly enough includes Karen, even though she left. And under the flex times on the 10th, it says that Ryan will cover reception, even though he now works at corporate. Yeah. And what is a flex time? You know, when I worked in admin, you needed to give the front receptionist a break so that that person could go to lunch. And so the other admin desks would rotate in to sit at the desk for lunch. So I was usually the receptionist. And then each day a different admin would take over my lunch hour because you couldn't have no one answering front reception or no one greeting guests.
8号有会计部门会议，上面特别注明“准备好展示你的工作成果”。10号写着“弹性时间”，有趣的是，尽管凯伦已经离职了，上面还包括了她。在10号的弹性时间下面，写着瑞安将负责前台，尽管他现在在总公司工作。是的。什么是弹性时间？你知道，当我在行政部门工作时，你需要给前台接待员休息时间，这样那个人才能去吃午饭。所以其他行政人员会轮流坐在前台吃午饭。所以我通常是那个接待员。然后每天会有不同的行政人员接替我的午餐时间，因为你不能让前台没人接听电话，也不能没人接待客人。
So I always assumed that's what it meant that like flex time was who rotated to give Pam her lunch break. But I don't know. I would have loved to see that scene. I would have loved to see like just. Just a montage of, like, different people answering the phones. Well, yes. So Dwight hands Angela the receipt for all the items in the baskets, and she's very icy towards him, Jenna.
所以我一直以为这就是它的意思，即弹性时间就是轮流给帕姆午休时间的人。但我不知道。我真希望能看到那个场景。我真希望能看到一个蒙太奇剪辑，展示不同的人接听电话。好吧，是的。所以德怀特把篮子里所有物品的收据交给安吉拉，她对他非常冷淡，珍娜。
She just wants it to be business, just business. Yeah. And he says, I miss you. And she's like, elevators. Yeah. And then when they get to the elevators, Angela is making it very clear that it's over. And Dwight is kind of like, okay, okay. I do want to be friends, plus a little extra also, I love you.
她只想公事公办，纯粹的公事。是的。他说，我想你。她却说，电梯。是的。然后当他们到达电梯时，安吉拉明确表示一切都结束了。德怀特有点像，好吧，好吧。我想做朋友，再加上一点额外的，我也爱你。
This is one of my favorite things that Dwight ever says to Angela. I have seen this, like, stitched on a pillow. I've seen it on all of these Valentine's items. It's really cute. People have written this to their boyfriend, our girlfriend, and they've shared it with me online. But that plus a little extra also, I love you. It's so great. I actually broke up with a guy once, and he was like, I get it totally cool.
这是德怀特对安吉拉说过的话里我最喜欢的一句。我见过这句话被绣在枕头上。我在所有这些情人节商品上都见过它。真的很可爱。人们把这句话写给他们的男朋友或女朋友，并在网上分享给我。但那句“再加上一点额外的，我也爱你”。太棒了。我曾经和一个人分手，他说，我懂，完全没问题。
Can we still hook up? And I was like, no, we cannot. That is not breaking up. And he seemed genuinely confused about it, which makes me laugh because we're now going into the scene with Ryan and Kelly in the break room. What a mess. These two. Yeah. Ryan and Kelly are arguing.
我们还能继续约炮吗？我说，不，我们不能。那不叫分手。他似乎真的对此感到困惑，这让我发笑，因为我们现在要进入瑞安和凯利在休息室的场景了。真是一团糟。这两个人。是的。瑞安和凯利在争吵。
And Ryan is like, you lied about being. pregnant. You lied. You don't understand why that's a big deal. And Mindy is Kelly is so good in this. She's like, oh, why? He's like, we will never get back together. And she's like, why not? It's so good. It's really good. Well, now Pam and Jim are at front reception and they're being super flirty. Yeah. They're flirting. He's saying, you know, oh, is the magic gone now that we're public. And then Pam's being sort of sassy but flirty at the same time. Well, this is their new way of flirting, which is to pretend that they don't like each other or that they're breaking up. So they do this little bit.
瑞安说，你撒谎说你怀孕了。你撒谎了。你不明白为什么这很重要吗？明迪，也就是凯利，在这里演得太好了。她说，哦，为什么？他说，我们永远不会复合了。她说，为什么不呢？太棒了。真的很好。好吧，现在帕姆和吉姆在前台，他们调情得厉害。是的。他们在调情。他说，你知道，哦，既然我们公开了，魔法消失了吗？然后帕姆表现得既傲慢又调情。好吧，这是他们新的调情方式，就是假装他们不喜欢对方，或者他们正在分手。所以他们演了这一出。
And this is a little window into how they still have their sense of humor, even though they're together. Don't worry everybody. The magic is not lost. Yeah. The magic isn't lost. We're just all going to have to watch them flirt now. Also, two things from Pam's desk. There is an orange kind of rust-colored ceramic pot with a very sad tiny plant, you know, because Pam could care less about plants now like she ever really cared, but her focus is elsewhere.
这是他们如何保持幽默感的一点缩影，即使他们在一起了。别担心，大家。魔法没有消失。是的。魔法没有消失。我们现在都得看着他们调情了。另外，帕姆桌上有两样东西。有一个橙色、铁锈色的陶瓷花盆，里面有一株非常可怜的小植物，你知道，因为帕姆现在根本不在乎植物，就像她以前真的在乎过一样，但她的注意力在别处。
And then Jenna, Pam, and Angela in real life have something in common. What? At 24 minutes, 22 seconds, you can see a whole bunch of yellow. Post-it notes that Pam has put in her desk area. Oh my gosh. Pam did like Post-it notes. Pam and Angela like Post-it notes. Yeah.
然后珍娜，帕姆和安吉拉在现实生活中有一个共同点。什么？在24分22秒，你可以看到帕姆在她的办公桌区域贴了一大堆黄色便利贴。天哪。帕姆确实喜欢便利贴。帕姆和安吉拉都喜欢便利贴。是的。
Yeah, it's true. Yeah, I did a lot of prop post-it note work on the show. Well, you know who likes Post-it notes in real life. You? Me. You love a Post-it. I love a Post-it. Why are you not like some sort of spokesperson?
是的，是真的。是的，我在节目中做了很多便利贴道具工作。好吧，你知道现实生活中谁喜欢便利贴吗？你？我。你喜欢便利贴。我喜欢便利贴。你为什么不是便利贴的代言人？
for Post-It Notes, I don't know. I actually did a campaign with Post-Its a few years ago, and they sent me a humongous box of every kind of different type of Post-It you could imagine. And I was over the moon. I did a crazy thing with Post-it Notes. It was early in the run of the office. Wired Magazine wanted me to do like a nude cover. Yeah.
我不知道。几年前我确实和便利贴做过一次活动，他们寄给我一个巨大的盒子，里面有你能想象到的各种便利贴。我当时高兴坏了。我用便利贴做了一件疯狂的事。那是在《办公室》刚开播的时候。《连线》杂志想让我拍一张裸体封面。是的。
But I wasn't nude. their pitch was that I was covered in post-it notes. And so they built me like a nude bodysuit. And then I came out onto the set in this nude body suit and then like a prop person had to slowly cover me in post-it notes. It was super odd. And I was like, I guess this is what you do when your TV show is a hit.
但我不是真的裸体。他们的构思是我身上贴满了便利贴。所以他们给我做了一件裸色紧身衣。然后我穿着这件紧身衣来到片场，然后一个道具师不得不慢慢地用便利贴覆盖我。这太奇怪了。我当时想，我想这就是当你的电视剧大火时你会做的事。
And they ask you to do the cover of a magazine, a man covers you in post-it notes. Jenna, you should have worn it to an award show. You would have been all the rage. Remember the lady at the Oscars? She was a wardrobe designer and she made a whole dress out of American Express cards, gold cards. Do you remember that? Yeah, yeah.
当他们让你拍杂志封面时，一个男人用便利贴覆盖你。珍娜，你应该穿着它去参加颁奖典礼。你会成为全场的焦点。还记得奥斯卡颁奖典礼上的那位女士吗？她是一位服装设计师，她用美国运通卡，金卡，做了一整件裙子。你记得吗？是的，是的。
You could have shown up in a post-it-note couture gown. Well, lady, I think we know who needs to show up in a post-it-note couture gown to something and it's you. And this is in your future. And it can still happen. Oh, my God. So Michael is going to unveil his plan, you guys, to win back clients. He makes his big announcement. He's going to be delivering baskets door to door.
你本可以穿着一件便利贴高级定制礼服出现。好吧，女士，我想我们知道谁需要穿着便利贴高级定制礼服出现在某个场合了，那就是你。这在你的未来。而且这仍然可能发生。天哪。所以迈克尔要向大家公布他的计划，赢回客户。他宣布了一个大消息。他要挨家挨户送篮子。
Unannounced, he's not going to warn anyone he's coming. Oh, yeah. It's a surprise gift basket, everybody. Ryan's not happy. We have a Michael talking head where he's like, you know what? He used to be told he couldn't do things like be on the team or move on to second grade. Jenna, are we finding out in this episode that Michael was held back in first grade? Yeah, I think we are.
不请自来，他不会提前通知任何人他要来。哦，是的。这是一个惊喜礼品篮，大家。瑞安很不高兴。我们有一个迈克尔的采访片段，他说，你知道吗？他以前被告知他不能做某些事情，比如加入球队或升入二年级。珍娜，我们是在这一集里发现迈克尔在一年级留级了吗？是的，我想是的。
I think we're learning maybe he was held back more than once, it sort of sounds like. Yeah, because then he's like, I eventually went on to second grade and I was the biggest in the class. Eventually? Again, what happened in Michael's childhood? Why was he held back in first grade so many times? And now we cut back to the bullpen. And Jenna, people are starting to yell out things and we have some major Phyllis sass. She says, Michael, this is stupid.
我想我们可能了解到他不止一次留级，听起来像是这样。是的，因为后来他说，我最终升入了二年级，我是班里最大的。最终？再说一次，迈克尔的童年发生了什么？为什么他在一年级留级了那么多次？现在我们切回办公区。珍娜，人们开始大喊大叫，我们看到了菲利斯的一些重大讽刺。她说，迈克尔，这太蠢了。
She just lays it out. Lays it out. Yeah. And then Andy suggests he give away cash instead. Yeah. And then he says, Angela, cash basket. Cash basket. You guys, cash basket became an inside joke for all of us on the office for years and years and years.
她直接说了出来。说了出来。是的。然后安迪建议他改送现金。是的。然后他说，安吉拉，现金篮。现金篮。伙计们，现金篮成了我们《办公室》剧组多年来的一个内部笑话。
Every once in a while there would be some line or some joke that. It just struck us as particularly funny in the moment and we couldn't get over it. And cash basket was one of them. I think if my memory serves, Angela, there was a take where Ed was maybe late to saying cash basket. And so it came out like this. Cash basket. And that made John Krasinski lose it. Well, I think it was the very first take.
每隔一段时间就会有一句台词或一个笑话，让我们在当时觉得特别好笑，我们无法忘怀。现金篮就是其中之一。如果我没记错的话，安吉拉，有一个镜头是艾德可能晚说了“现金篮”。所以它出来的时候是这样的：现金篮。这让约翰·卡拉辛斯基笑场了。好吧，我想那是第一个镜头。
And a few things happened. We hadn't really heard him say it full out, right? Yep. So it kind of took all of us off guard. And John was like right there next to him when Ed was like, Cash Basket. And we just lost it. But John really, he really lost it. I watched really closely because I was surprised they had a reaction shot of John at all in this scene. Because my memory of doing this scene was that John was on the floor in tears laughing the entire time because he couldn't get past Cash Basket. Well, I did notice, though, because I was looking as well, he kind of is swiveling his chair around, but he glances back towards Andy, and that is just John looking at Ed. That is not, that is not Jim looking at Andy. He just has this look of like, man, like this guy is killing me today. Well, after I watched this episode, it really made me want to go to our office text thread and just text cash basket. Oh, we should.
发生了一些事情。我们还没真正听他完整地说出来，对吧？是的。所以这让我们所有人都措手不及。当艾德说“现金篮”时，约翰就在他旁边。我们直接笑疯了。但约翰真的，他真的笑场了。我观察得很仔细，因为我很惊讶在这个场景中约翰竟然有反应镜头。因为我做这个场景的记忆是，约翰当时在地上笑得流泪，因为他无法跨过“现金篮”这个梗。好吧，我确实注意到了，因为我也在看，他转动椅子，但他回头看了看安迪，那只是约翰在看艾德。那不是吉姆在看安迪。他只是有一种眼神，好像在说，天哪，这家伙今天要把我笑死了。好吧，看完这一集后，我真的很想去我们的办公室群聊里发一句“现金篮”。哦，我们应该发。
Well, Michael is just like, forget it, guys, I am going, I'm going to do this. And then Dwight begs him, can I please go with you? I need this. And at 26 minutes, 41 seconds, Angela Martin is looking over the partition. She has a really great eye roll. But guys, look how high my head is over that partition. It's not realistic at all. Really and truly that partition came up to my forehead.
好吧，迈克尔只是说，算了吧，伙计们，我要去，我要这么做。然后德怀特求他，我能和你一起去吗？我需要这个。在26分41秒，安吉拉·马丁正从隔板上方看过来。她翻了一个很棒的白眼。但伙计们，看看我的头在隔板上方有多高。这根本不现实。真的，那个隔板高到我的额头。
And I would have to stand on my tippy toes to get my eyeballs over it to talk to Jenna. I was standing on the biggest apple box. It made me laugh. When I saw it, I'm like, who is this tall person pretending to be me? And I took a picture, Jenna. I'm going to show you. That is amazing. Yes, there is no way that that is you standing there because your chin never cleared the partition.
我必须踮起脚尖才能把眼睛露出来和珍娜说话。我当时站在最大的苹果箱上。这让我笑了。当我看到它时，我想，这个假装成我的高个子是谁？我拍了一张照片，珍娜。我要给你看。那太神奇了。是的，你站在那里绝对不可能是你，因为你的下巴从来没有超过隔板。
I know, I know. Naturally. No. There's no way. Well, I really like this Michael talking head that comes up, Angela, where he says, I'd like to see a website deliver baskets of food to people. I know. As if it's like a novelty. Hi, that's like half of Christmas is just sending people baskets. I send everyone in my family a whole thing of mixed nuts. I love nuts. They're a big hit. A basket of mixed nuts? Yes, all kinds of mixed nuts. for sure and there's I mean guys there's many flavors there's the Cajun nuts there's pecans or the caramelized ones just saying Michael people are doing it well Michael is going to bring Dwight with him and they're going to deliver these gift baskets and they are in the car now they're on their way here's one question I have and yeah these gift baskets are very very large where are they where are they are they going back and forth to dunder mifflin it looks like there's one in the backseat well there's a camera operator in the back seat clearly filming them yeah it seems like there's only room
我知道，我知道。自然地。不。绝对不可能。好吧，我真的很喜欢这个迈克尔的采访片段，安吉拉，他说，我想看看哪个网站能给人们送食物篮。我知道。好像这是一种新奇事物。嗨，圣诞节的一半就是给人们送篮子。我给家里每个人都寄了一大份混合坚果。我喜欢坚果。它们很受欢迎。一篮混合坚果？是的，各种混合坚果。肯定的，而且伙计们，有很多口味，有卡津坚果，有山核桃，还有焦糖味的，我只是说，迈克尔，人们都在这么做。好吧，迈克尔要带德怀特一起去，他们要送这些礼品篮，他们现在在车里，他们在路上。我有一个问题，这些礼品篮非常非常大，它们在哪儿？它们在哪儿？它们要往返于邓德·米夫林吗？看起来后座有一个，好吧，后座有一个摄像师在拍摄他们，是的，看起来只有空间
for one more but we're going to see them deliver a few where are they coming from is that can one fit in the trunk i don't know i wondered where the basket how big is the trunk of a ford torus that's a question that's a question well i have a thing i'm curious curious about. So Michael and Dwight are in the car. They're driving. The GPS starts talking to them. By the way, it looks like a Garmin. I remember because I had one for a while, just saying, okay. And Dwight's like, why do you use that? It will let them know where you are. Michael's like, what are you talking about? And he's like, the government, spy satellites, private detectives, ex-girlfriends. And then he starts to cry. And Michael has no reaction. Wouldn't you be like,
再放一个，但我们要看他们送几个。它们是从哪儿来的？后备箱能放下一个吗？我不知道，我很好奇篮子，福特金牛座的后备箱有多大？这是一个问题，这是一个问题。好吧，我有一件事很好奇。所以迈克尔和德怀特在车里。他们在开车。GPS开始和他们说话。顺便说一句，看起来像个佳明。我记得因为我有一段时间用过一个，只是说，好吧。德怀特说，你为什么要用那个？它会让别人知道你在哪儿。迈克尔说，你在说什么？他说，政府、间谍卫星、私家侦探、前女友。然后他开始哭。迈克尔没有任何反应。你难道不会说，
Like, why are you crying? What is happening? Yeah, probably. Dude's not like dudes out there. If your friend cries, are you not like, what's up? Are you just like, I'm going to ignore it, maybe he'll stop? Like, what is that? Is that a dude bro thing?
比如，你为什么哭？发生了什么？是的，可能吧。男人不是那种……如果你的朋友哭了，你难道不会问，怎么了？你只是想，我要无视它，也许他会停下来？那是什么？那是男人的那种兄弟行为吗？
I don't know. Well, we had a fan question about this scene. Callie Hendricks and Brendan Cullinan asked, how did you guys do the GPS voicing? Was it a voice actor? and if so, who voiced it? Yes, it was. It was a voice actor.
我不知道。好吧，我们有一个关于这个场景的粉丝问题。卡莉·亨德里克斯和布伦丹·库里南问，你们是怎么做GPS配音的？是配音演员吗？如果是，是谁配的？是的，确实是。是一位配音演员。
It was an actress named Lynn Ann Zager. And we just hired her and she read all the GPS voice stuff. Well, she did great. She sounds like the real deal. I know. Jenna, my friend Micah, you know, he's from Australia. And he set his GPS to the Aussie, the Aussie lady. So she's like, oh, take it right.
是一位叫琳·安·扎格的女演员。我们雇了她，她读了所有GPS语音的内容。好吧，她做得很好。她听起来就像真的一样。我知道。珍娜，我的朋友迈卡，你知道，他是澳大利亚人。他把他的GPS设置成了澳洲口音，澳洲女士。所以她说，哦，向右转。
No, you can do this. Yes, you can. You can have like, like, I know you can have British, but he picked the Australian. Oh, I kind of want to do this now. Yeah, I know. Is that great? Exit for Studio City. Oh, my God.
不，你能做到。是的，你可以。你可以有，比如，我知道你可以有英式口音，但他选了澳大利亚口音。哦，我现在有点想这么做了。是的，我知道。那不是很棒吗？出口去工作室城。天哪。
I kind of love that. You know, there's this app, this meditation app called Headspace. I don't know if you've ever heard of it. And you can choose between either a male or a female, I guess, meditation leader voice. I don't know what to call them, but they lead you through the meditation, and you can pick a man or a woman. And the man sounds exactly like our earwolf producer, Colin. Really? Yes, to the point where I had to change to the woman, because as much as I love Colin's voice, I felt like I was like, I was like, why is Colin who talks to me about download numbers and ad sales leading me through my meditation right now?
我有点喜欢这个。你知道，有一个应用程序，这个冥想应用程序叫Headspace。我不知道你有没有听说过。你可以选择男性或女性冥想引导者的声音。我不知道该怎么称呼他们，但他们引导你完成冥想，你可以选男人或女人。那个男人的声音听起来和我们的Earwolf制作人科林一模一样。真的吗？是的，以至于我不得不换成女人，因为尽管我喜欢科林的声音，但我感觉我好像在想，为什么那个跟我谈下载量和广告销售的科林现在在引导我冥想？
It's really funny. Jenna, what if we did navigation for people? Oh, my gosh. What would that sound like? It would sound like this. Lady, take a right. You are at your destination. I love it.
这真的很有趣。珍娜，如果我们为人们做导航会怎么样？天哪。那听起来会是什么样？它听起来会是这样。女士，向右转。你已到达目的地。我喜欢。
Oh, that's really good. All right. We should get back to the episode. Oh, man, oh, man. I loved the scene. It's in the kitchen. Ryan is trying to impress Andy and Kevin about his life in New York City. And he's like, yeah, at 2 a.m., you know, I went to get a sandwich because you can get a
哦，那真的很好。好吧。我们应该回到这一集。天哪，天哪。我喜欢这个场景。在厨房里。瑞安正试图在安迪和凯文面前炫耀他在纽约市的生活。他说，是的，凌晨2点，你知道，我去买三明治，因为你可以在纽约市凌晨2点买到
sandwich at 2 a.m. in New York City. He literally bumps into Vince Vaughn. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's incredible. And Andy says, you are so money, but you don't even know it. But you do know it. And that was a quote from the movie Swingers.
三明治。他真的撞见了文斯·沃恩。是的。是的。是的。太不可思议了。安迪说，你太有钱了，但你甚至不知道。但你确实知道。那是电影《摇摆者》里的一句台词。
Yeah. Do you remember that movie? It was from 1996. How could I forget that movie? It was like all of my friends were struggling actors. We were all broke and doing all these different odd jobs to pay rent while trying to go on auditions. And it was like this movie, we like felt seen. We're like, this is us.
是的。你记得那部电影吗？那是1996年的。我怎么会忘记那部电影？那就像我所有的朋友都是挣扎中的演员。我们都破产了，做着各种零工来付房租，同时试图去试镜。就像这部电影，我们觉得被看见了。我们想，这就是我们。
Oh, my God. It totally encapsulated the sort of like young L.A. Transplant lifestyle. And it was written by John Favreau and stars John Favreau and Vince Fawn. And Ron Livingston. Yes, directed by Doug Lyman. It launched all of their careers. And I remember this.
天哪。它完全概括了那种年轻的洛杉矶外来者的生活方式。它是由乔恩·费儒编剧，并由乔恩·费儒、文斯·沃恩和罗恩·利文斯顿主演。是的，由道格·里曼导演。它开启了他们所有人的职业生涯。我记得这个。
It features that club, the Dresden. Yeah. Do you remember the Dresden? It was this big swing dance club. Very hipster. Hipster club. Yeah. Well, here are the things.
它以那个俱乐部，德累斯顿为特色。是的。你记得德累斯顿吗？那是一个很大的摇摆舞俱乐部。非常嬉皮。嬉皮俱乐部。是的。好吧，这里是这些东西。
I have to read this off because it really got me tickled. You know, Jim is like, I can't believe you guys are impressed with this guy. You know, he's like, whatever, with Ryan and his 2 a.m. sandwich, you know. And Andy's like, listen, this is why Ryan is awesome. Are you ready? Yeah. Number one, killer job. Number two, he's rich.
我得读一下这个，因为它真的让我觉得很有趣。你知道，吉姆说，我不敢相信你们竟然被这家伙打动了。你知道，他说，随便吧，瑞安和他的凌晨2点三明治，你知道。安迪说，听着，这就是瑞安很棒的原因。准备好了吗？第一，杀手级工作。第二，他很有钱。
Number three, smells like Pierce Brosnan. Number four, wears really cool rich guy clothes. Number five can get any girl he wants. We'll see. We'll see. Well, now Michael and Dwight arrive to their first client. They're going to woo him back with their big gift basket. He is confused why they've come.
第三，闻起来像皮尔斯·布鲁斯南。第四，穿着非常酷的富人衣服。第五，能得到他想要的任何女孩。我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。好吧，现在迈克尔和德怀特到达了他们的第一个客户那里。他们要用他们的大礼品篮赢回他。他很困惑他们为什么来。
Yeah, also he's like, you don't have a website. We went with Office Depot because they have a really good website. Like what, I don't know why you're here. Yeah, it's a very funny scene. The actor who plays the client is named Edward James Gage, who, in addition to numerous acting roles also spent 13 years as a real-life private eye bounty hunter and bodyguard, according to his bio on IMDB. Okay, well, that's a pretty interesting resume there.
是的，他还说，你们没有网站。我们选择了Office Depot，因为他们有一个非常好的网站。就像什么，我不知道你们为什么在这里。是的，这是一个非常有趣的场景。扮演客户的演员叫爱德华·詹姆斯·盖奇，根据他在IMDB上的简历，除了众多的表演角色外，他还做了13年的现实生活中的私家侦探、赏金猎人和保镖。好吧，那简历确实很有趣。
Well, I have a question about this scene. I'm, I was a little confused what this business was. So the character's name is Larry, the client's name is Larry. And if you look over his shoulder, what is the crazy machine behind him? I've never seen anything like it. What is it? I don't know. And then it got me wondering, what is this company?
好吧，我有一个关于这个场景的问题。我有点困惑这是什么生意。所以角色的名字是拉里，客户的名字是拉里。如果你看他的肩膀后面，他身后那个疯狂的机器是什么？我从来没见过那样的东西。那是什么？我不知道。然后我开始好奇，这是什么公司？
Where have they gone? Do we ever find out? It was, it bothered me. It was a big mystery for me. It did not bother me. Didn't bother you. Didn't occur to you. Now I guess I have to go back and look at this machine.
他们去哪儿了？我们发现了吗？这困扰了我。对我来说这是一个大谜团。它没有困扰我。没困扰你。没出现在你脑海里。现在我想我得回去看看这台机器。
Guys, check it out. What is it? There must be someone out there who knows what it is. They're going to be like, oh, they make widgets for plastic airplanes. Like, it'll be obvious to someone. one and I'd love to know. Okay, me too, me too. Well, back at Dunder Mifflin, Ryan is going to do a real skeezy boss move. He's going to go up to Pam and be like, hey, do you want to do some mock-ups of the new Dunder Mifflin Infinity graphic and she's really excited. Her and Jim do an air
伙计们，去看看。那是什么？一定有人知道那是什么。他们会说，哦，他们制造塑料飞机的零件。就像，对某人来说这很明显。而且我很想知道。好吧，我也是，我也是。好吧，回到邓德·米夫林，瑞安要做一个非常卑鄙的老板举动。他要走到帕姆面前说，嘿，你想为新的邓德·米夫林无限图形做一些模型吗？她真的很兴奋。她和吉姆做了一个空中
high-five. And then you have a very adorable talking head, Jenna. I literally wrote, She's adorable. Aw, thanks. You're just like, yeah, I'm going to do some mock-ups, maybe a splash frame. It's really cute. But you're excited. Well, Michael is going to deliver his second basket now. Second basket.
击掌。然后你有一个非常可爱的采访片段，珍娜。我写的是，她很可爱。哦，谢谢。你只是说，是的，我要做一些模型，也许是一个启动画面。这真的很可爱。但你很兴奋。好吧，迈克尔现在要送他的第二个篮子了。第二个篮子。
Yeah, exactly. And this is where Michael is so great. I have to say Michael's argument that the personal touch means something, he walks in, he asks about the client's 11-year-old daughter. Emily, he remembered her name. He remembered she had a nut allergy. I mean, yeah, impressive and genuine. Yeah. But then he has that line that breaks your heart. Oh, I know. I know what you're going to say. Yeah, he says, well, I have a few of my own I want someday. Talking about kids. Yeah. Yeah. Michael. Well, the client's name is Aaron Grandi. He is a partner in this law firm, and he was played by Kevin Dorff. Kevin Dorff has had recurring roles on Brooklyn 9-9 and Arrested Development, but most recently, he played Bill O'Reilly in the movie, Bombshell. And I loved that movie. I haven't seen it. Is it a bombshell? Is it a war movie? Is it like bomb?
是的，没错。这就是迈克尔如此伟大的地方。我必须说迈克尔关于个人接触意味着什么的论点，他走进去，询问客户11岁的女儿。艾米丽，他记得她的名字。他记得她对坚果过敏。我的意思是，是的，令人印象深刻且真诚。是的。但后来他说了那句让你心碎的话。哦，我知道。我知道你要说什么。是的，他说，嗯，我希望有一天我也能有几个。谈论孩子。是的。是的。迈克尔。好吧，客户的名字是亚伦·格兰迪。他是这家律师事务所的合伙人，由凯文·多夫扮演。凯文·多夫在《神烦警探》和《发展受阻》中都有常驻角色，但最近，他在电影《爆炸新闻》中扮演了比尔·奥莱利。我喜欢那部电影。我没看过。它是爆炸新闻吗？它是战争电影吗？它像炸弹吗？
No, lady, it's not a warmie. It's a little bit of a war movie because there are a couple of women who take on a movie. I guess you could say. It's this amazing film. It's basically centers around Megan Kelly and Gretchen Carlson and their time at Fox News. They were their news anchors at Fox News or were. And Kevin Dorff plays Bill O'Reilly in this movie. Oh, wow. It's so good, Angela.
不，女士，它不是战争电影。它有点像战争电影，因为有几个女人挑战了一部电影。我想你可以这么说。这是一部了不起的电影。它基本上围绕着梅根·凯利和格雷琴·卡尔森以及她们在福克斯新闻的时间。她们是福克斯新闻的新闻主播，或者曾经是。凯文·多夫在这部电影中扮演比尔·奥莱利。哦，哇。太棒了，安吉拉。
And the makeup department on this film won an Academy Award and the transformation that they do to make people look like the real people. Like, Charlize Theron plays Megan Kelly. She really, really looks like her. Like, it freaked me out. I once shared a train with Megan Kelly. I didn't speak to her, but I sat right across from her on a train from New York to Washington, D.C. And so I've seen her in real life as well. And I'm telling you what this makeup department did was, I've never seen anything like it.
这部电影的化妆部门赢得了奥斯卡奖，他们为了让人看起来像真实人物所做的改造。比如，查理兹·塞隆扮演梅根·凯利。她看起来真的很像她。这让我很震惊。我曾经和梅根·凯利坐过同一列火车。我没和她说话，但我坐在从纽约到华盛顿特区的火车上，就坐在她对面。所以我也在现实生活中见过她。我告诉你，这个化妆部门所做的事情，我从来没见过。
But also, the movie is amazing. Okay. Well, Jenna, I'll add bombshell to my cue. please do and we'll discuss after okay and how cool that how cool that Kevin has a part in it I know I also want to say in this scene though the background acting behind the glass doors over the client's shoulder yeah you get a glimpse at the law firm it is hustle and bustle in there there is so much going on I mean the background work is phenomenal they're moving they're moving and they're making it they're making it Yeah. Well, Michael's really trying hard. He wants this client back. He says, we want you back. And Dwight starts getting a little weird because he's just thinking about Angela. And he goes, we had our chance and we killed it. And you just have this feeling that this is not going to go well for them. Yeah. Well, it's definitely not going to go well because the big moment is about to happen. I think we should take a break. I like how you're setting this up, though. The big moment is about to happen. It's a big moment. It was a big stunt. Hey, it's not every day you drive a car into a lake, guys,
而且，这部电影太棒了。好吧。好吧，珍娜，我会把《爆炸新闻》加入我的待看清单。请务必加入，我们看完再讨论，好吗？凯文在里面有角色真是太酷了。我知道，我也想说在这个场景中，客户肩膀后面玻璃门后的背景表演，是的，你可以瞥见律师事务所，那里非常繁忙，有很多事情在发生，我的意思是背景工作非常出色，他们在移动，他们在制造，他们在制造。是的。好吧，迈克尔真的很努力。他想赢回这个客户。他说，我们想让你回来。德怀特开始变得有点奇怪，因为他只是在想安吉拉。他说，我们有机会，但我们搞砸了。你只是有种感觉，这对他们来说不会有好结果。是的。好吧，这绝对不会有好结果，因为大时刻即将到来。我想我们应该休息一下。我喜欢你这样铺垫，大时刻即将到来。这是一个大时刻。这是一个大特技。嘿，不是每天你都会把车开进湖里，伙计们，
and we're going to tell you all about it after this break. All right, we are back. Jen and I are really excited because we have fun stuff to share with you about this car going into the lake. So here's the scene. Dwight says They have one more client It's Elmhurst Country Club I looked it up Jenna
我们会在休息后告诉你所有关于它的事情。好吧，我们回来了。珍娜和我真的很兴奋，因为我们有有趣的事情要和你们分享关于这辆车开进湖里的事。所以这是场景。德怀特说他们还有一个客户，是埃尔姆赫斯特乡村俱乐部。我查过了，珍娜。
Elmhurst Country Club Is in Moscow, Pennsylvania Oh In Lackawanna County Okay So they're following the GPS And it's telling them to take a right And Dwight is like Michael
埃尔姆赫斯特乡村俱乐部在宾夕法尼亚州的莫斯科。哦，在拉卡瓦纳县。好吧，所以他们跟着GPS。它告诉他们向右转，德怀特说，迈克尔。
I think it means bear right Right and Michael's like No it's telling me to take a hard right And Dwight's like no Michael that's the lake It's Lake Scranton And Michael's like no The GPS is telling us
我想它的意思是靠右。迈克尔说，不，它告诉我要急转弯。德怀特说，不，迈克尔，那是湖。那是斯克兰顿湖。迈克尔说，不，GPS在告诉我。
me? And he drives into the lake. Right into the lake. Well, we got a lot of mail about this scene. David B. Rachel K., Rob Holland, Thomas O'Brien, and many others all asked, please tell us everything you can about the scene where Steve and Rain drive into the lake. Did they really drive a car into the lake? Was there a camera operator in the back seat? Yes, for Folks, let's break it down. But yes to all of that. Well, I started by reaching out to Steve. And he said, yes, they really drove a real car into a real lake.
我？然后他把车开进了湖里。直接开进了湖里。好吧，我们收到了很多关于这个场景的邮件。大卫·B、瑞秋·K、罗布·霍兰德、托马斯·奥布莱恩和许多其他人，都问，请告诉我们关于史蒂夫和雷恩把车开进湖里的场景的一切。他们真的把车开进湖里了吗？后座有摄像师吗？是的，伙计们，让我们分解一下。但对所有这些问题的回答都是肯定的。好吧，我首先联系了史蒂夫。他说，是的，他们真的把一辆真车开进了一个真湖里。
He said they did the stunt twice all the way through. And that Randall, our camera operator, was in the back seat. So, of course, Angela, I had to reach out to Randall. Oh, oh, what did he say? Well, first of all, do you know where he was when I reached out to him? Listen, knowing Randall, I mean, was he on horseback somewhere? The guy is an adventure guy. Was he skydiving?
他说他们把这个特技完整地做了两次。而且兰德尔，我们的摄像师，在后座。所以，当然，安吉拉，我不得不联系兰德尔。哦，哦，他说了什么？好吧，首先，你知道我联系他时他在哪儿吗？听着，了解兰德尔，我的意思是，他在某个地方骑马吗？这家伙是个冒险家。他在跳伞吗？
Where was he? He was just finishing up a river rafting trip in Idaho on a freezing cold lake. Of course. Of course. But because Randall is awesome, he still broke down the whole stunt for me, which is completely fascinating. From Idaho. From on his drive home. from Idaho, from the freezing cold lake.
他在哪儿？他刚在爱达荷州的一个冰冷的湖上结束了一次漂流旅行。当然。当然。但因为兰德尔很棒，他还是为我分解了整个特技，这非常迷人。从爱达荷州。在他回家的路上。从爱达荷州，从那个冰冷的湖。
When I first reached out to him, he literally said, I'm just getting out of a lake, which was ironic. Perfect. But I'll call you on my drive home. I was like, all right. Amazing. This is great. All right. So he says, first off, they did not actually drive the car into the lake.
当我第一次联系他时，他真的说，我刚从湖里出来，这很讽刺。完美。但我会在回家的路上给你打电话。我说，好吧。太棒了。这太好了。好吧。所以他说，首先，他们并没有真的把车开进湖里。
They put the car on a system that hold it into the lake and stopped it at a certain depth. So there was a rig to make it look like. like they were driving into a lake. So it was on some type of track pulley thing? Yes. Okay. And he said they did this because they needed to control how much water flooded into the car. Makes sense.
他们把车放在一个系统上，把它拉进湖里，并在一定深度停住。所以有一个装置让它看起来像。像他们正在开车进湖里。所以它是在某种轨道滑轮上？是的。好吧。他说他们这样做是因为他们需要控制有多少水涌进车里。有道理。
Yeah. Yes. He said the car actually didn't even have an engine. They had to take it out. It didn't have a gas tank. It didn't have any oil. All of that was removed to submerge it in water. I found that interesting.
是的。他说这辆车甚至连引擎都没有。他们不得不把它拆掉。它没有油箱。它没有油。所有这些都被移除了，以便把它淹没在水里。我觉得这很有趣。
Yeah. But he told me he really was scrunched in the backseat with a giant gift basket next to him. So he said at first, they discussed just filming it on lipstick cameras that were in the visors. You know, we've seen them do that before. But Randall felt very strongly that it should be shot using the handheld camera from the back seat. So he kind of fought for that. And is that because it just, the look of it would be better? You would really feel that water coming in because it's just a better camera. Yeah. And you can't pan the lipstick cameras. They're just like a They're stationary.
是的。但他告诉我，他确实蜷缩在后座，旁边放着一个巨大的礼品篮。所以他说起初，他们讨论只是用遮阳板里的口红摄像机拍摄。你知道，我们以前见过他们那样做。但兰德尔强烈认为应该用后座的手持摄像机拍摄。所以他争取了这一点。这是因为它的外观会更好吗？你会真正感觉到水涌进来，因为这是一个更好的摄像机。是的。而且你不能平移口红摄像机。它们只是像一个，它们是固定的。
They only get that one little window that you're seeing, whereas Randall with a handheld camera could get the whole view. Yes, exactly. He said that the camera that he was using, it cost upwards of $130,000. Holy cow. And he could not get it wet. He was told, you cannot ruin this camera.
它们只能得到你看到的那个小窗口，而兰德尔用手持摄像机可以得到整个视野。是的，完全正确。他说他使用的摄像机价值超过13万美元。天哪。而且他不能让它弄湿。他被告知，你不能毁了这台摄像机。
And they put some kind of like protective housing on it, but he said he still had to like, like, lift his butt off the back seat to keep the camera from dipping into the water. Oh, my God, no pressure. Also, Randall, I mean, he's a big guy. And he's scrunched in the back of this Ford Taurus with a gift basket and a camera that costs like, I mean, my God, it's like. As much as a house. He's holding a house.
他们给它装了某种保护壳，但他还是不得不，比如，把屁股抬离后座，以防止摄像机浸入水中。天哪，没压力。还有，兰德尔，我的意思是，他是个大块头。他蜷缩在这辆福特金牛座的后座，带着一个礼品篮和一台价值，我的意思是，天哪，就像。像房子一样。他拿着一栋房子。
Yes, he's holding a house, basically. Dang. He told me that for sound purposes, they had a wire on both Steve and Rain. and they used these waterproof mic packs called The Countryman. Oh. Which Randall knew about from Survivor. Because remember, he spent all that time on Survivor. Yes.
是的，他基本上拿着一栋房子。该死。他告诉我，为了声音效果，他们在史蒂夫和雷恩身上都装了线。他们使用了这些防水麦克风包，叫Countryman。哦。兰德尔从《幸存者》节目中知道这个。因为记得吗，他在《幸存者》上花了很多时间。是的。
He said they also put mics in the visors. And they had boom operators standing outside of the car in water. So our boom guys were like in like those like rubber pants in the water. Yes. Randall confirmed that they did three takes, but they were losing daylight on the last one. And he's pretty certain that we use the first take because everybody's reactions to hitting the water were just so pure.
他说他们还在遮阳板里放了麦克风。而且他们有吊杆操作员站在车外的水里。所以我们的吊杆人员就像穿着那种橡胶裤在水里。是的。兰德尔证实他们拍了三次，但最后一次他们失去了日光。他很确定我们用了第一次拍摄，因为每个人对撞击水的反应都太纯粹了。
Yeah. And he said that there are only two cut points in this scene. So the first cut point is when the camera pans down to the GPS. That's when they cut into the car being on the rig. I mean, you can't even tell. It's seamless. I watched it like five times and I couldn't figure out. a great job. How they did it. And he said, and then after that point, it is all one shot
是的。他说这个场景只有两个剪辑点。所以第一个剪辑点是摄像机向下平移到GPS时。那是他们剪辑到车在装置上的时候。我的意思是，你甚至看不出来。它是无缝的。我看了五遍，我没看出来。做得很好。他们是怎么做的。他说，在那之后，它是一个镜头
until you see the shot of the basket floating in the water. And that's when they cut away and they reset to get all the stuff of Michael and Dwight crawling out of the lake. But all of that commotion of getting out of the car and like Steve hanging on to the passenger side window and opening the door, that was all one take. And that was what Randall was fighting for. He was saying Lipstick cams could have never, ever picked up. Yeah. I have a question. As Steve is making his way out and he's clinging on to the side of the car, he opens the back passenger door.
直到你看到篮子漂在水里的镜头。那时他们切断了，他们重置以拍摄迈克尔和德怀特从湖里爬出来的所有东西。但所有那些从车里出来的骚动，比如史蒂夫挂在乘客侧窗户上并打开门，那都是一个镜头。而这就是兰德尔争取的东西。他说口红摄像机永远永远无法捕捉到。是的。我有一个问题。当史蒂夫出来并紧紧抓住车身时，他打开了后排乘客门。
And was that to let Randall out? Well, we had a lot of people writing about that. They said, is Michael trying to save the camera operator or the gift basket? Yeah. And I asked Randall and Randall said, my instinct would be the gift basket. He's like, I never thought that Michael was opening the door for me. But I thought, it's funny, I gave credit to Michael. I thought Michael was trying to free the camera operator.
那是为了让兰德尔出来吗？好吧，我们有很多人写信问这个问题。他们说，迈克尔是在试图救摄像师还是礼品篮？是的。我问了兰德尔，兰德尔说，我的直觉会是礼品篮。他说，我从来没想过迈克尔是在为我开门。但我认为，很有趣，我把功劳给了迈克尔。我以为迈克尔是在试图解救摄像师。
Yeah. Well, at 35 minutes, 17 seconds, there is a absolutely perfect shot of our camera operator's shadow across the lake. I saw that too. I was surprised I didn't see boom mic shadows. I was looking for boom shadows and I didn't see them. I was impressed. But yes, the camera operator shadow is there. Well, Jenna, I reached out to Rain because I was like, Rain, what was it like?
是的。好吧，在35分17秒，有一个绝对完美的镜头，是我们摄像师的影子投射在湖面上。我也看到了。我很惊讶我没有看到吊杆麦克风的影子。我在找吊杆的影子，但我没看到。我印象深刻。但是的，摄像师的影子在那里。好吧，珍娜，我联系了雷恩，因为我想，雷恩，那是什么感觉？
Driving into the lake, I texted him and he sent us an audio clip. Sam, can you play it? Hi, office ladies. It's me, Rain. Angela called and asked me if I had any memories about driving into the lake. And my main fear wasn't like drowning or the car or anything like that. It was kind of like, this water is not the cleanest. And there's all these houses all over the place.
开车进湖里，我给他发了短信，他给我们发了一个音频片段。萨姆，你能播放吗？嗨，办公室女士们。是我，雷恩。安吉拉打电话问我是否对开车进湖里有什么记忆。我主要的恐惧不是溺水或车什么的。而是有点像，这水不太干净。而且到处都是房子。
And I just knew it was pretty sewagey. And I was just really afraid of like an eye infection or something like that. It was like kind of eerily warm the water. It was not cold at all. But it was super fun. I mean, I love a chance to do a stunt. I was really excited to be a part of it. And, I mean, how often do you get to kind of drive your car into a lake?
我知道它相当脏。我真的很怕眼睛感染什么的。水温有点诡异地暖和。一点也不冷。但这超级有趣。我的意思是，我喜欢有机会做特技。我真的很兴奋能参与其中。而且，我的意思是，你多久能有机会把车开进湖里？
It was fantastic, so much fun to shoot. And I wish I had more specifics, but it was just one of those kind of days where you're kind of like, wow, this is what I do for a living today. I'm playing a fictional weirdo. driving my car into a lake and with Steve Correll, I mean, it was pretty, it was pretty great. Okay. I love you. Goodbye.
这太棒了，拍摄起来很有趣。我希望我有更多的细节，但这只是那种你觉得，哇，这就是我今天谋生的方式的日子。我正在扮演一个虚构的怪人，把车开进湖里，和史蒂夫·卡瑞尔一起，我的意思是，这太棒了。好吧。我爱你。再见。
I love that Rain's biggest concern was getting pink eye. I don't want to get a sty today, guys. Not today. I would have had so many concerns doing this stunt. It did kind of gross me out that he said the water was oddly warm. And you have to remember, we filmed this at Malibu Lake, and that is a man-made lake. So there isn't like anything flowing into it, you know, it is. Probably a little stagnant.
我喜欢Rain最担心的是得红眼病。伙计们，我今天可不想长麦粒肿。今天不行。如果是我来做这个特技，我会有很多顾虑。他说水温异常温暖，这确实让我觉得有点恶心。你们得记住，我们是在马里布湖拍摄的，那是一个人工湖。所以没有什么东西流入其中，你知道，它可能有点死水。
Well, I have to point something out. When the tow truck pulls the car out, Jenna, the passenger door is shut, but Michael opened it. Oh, yeah. Yeah. And then the other thing I was thinking about was, did Michael and Dwight just happen to have their windows down? Because they climb out through their windows. I'm like, what are they driving around with their windows down? So there are little moments like that that were just sort of like, I was like, huh, okay, guys.
嗯，我得指出一点。当拖车把车拉出来时，Jenna，乘客侧的车门是关着的，但Michael打开了它。哦，对。对。还有一件事我一直在想，Michael和Dwight是不是刚好把车窗摇下来了？因为他们是从车窗爬出来的。我在想，他们开车时为什么要摇下车窗？所以像这样的小细节，我当时就觉得，嗯，好吧，伙计们。
Well, when I was emailing with Steve about this scene, Angela, he reminded me that we got a lot of pushback after this episode aired because of this moment. He said, people kind of thought it was a little over the top, that it was unrealistic that someone would follow their GPS into a lake. Yeah, people were like, no way, that would never happen. But he told me that the writers based this on a series of real life incidents of people following their GPS. GPS into perilous situations. So I reached out to Greg and he said this was a pitch by Jen Salada. So of course, I had to follow this trail. I reached out to Jen.
嗯，当我和Steve通过邮件讨论这个场景时，Angela，他提醒我，这一集播出后，因为这个情节，我们受到了很多抵制。他说，人们觉得这有点夸张，觉得有人会跟着GPS开进湖里是不现实的。是的，人们说，不可能，那永远不会发生。但他告诉我，编剧们是基于一系列真实发生的事件，即人们跟着GPS进入危险境地。所以我联系了Greg，他说这是Jen Salada提出的点子。所以当然，我必须顺藤摸瓜。我联系了Jen。
What did Jen say? She said during the hiatus before season four, she went home to visit her parents in Maryland and she was sitting in the back seat of their brand new minivan. She specified it was a Honda Odyssey minivan. She picked up the owner's manual and was reading about the minivan's GPS system. She said that on the very first page of the manual, there was a warning that said, do not drive your car into any bodies of water, even if the GPS tells you to. And Jen was like, what? Who would do that?
Jen说了什么？她说在第四季之前的空档期，她回家探望在马里兰州的父母，当时她正坐在他们那辆全新小型货车的后座。她特别说明那是本田奥德赛小型货车。她拿起车主手册，读到了关于小型货车GPS系统的说明。她说在手册的第一页，有一个警告写着：即使GPS指示你这样做，也不要将车开进任何水域。Jen当时就想，什么？谁会那样做？
You know, Honda had to put that in there because someone had done it. Yes. And she was like, wait a second. you know who would do that, Michael Scott would do that. Yes, he would. So she said, before she pitched it, because she was a little worried it was too crazy of an idea, she researched this phenomenon. And she said there were so many cases of people doing things like driving their cars off of a cliff or into water because their GPS told them to.
你知道，本田必须把它写进去，因为确实有人这么做过。是的，她当时就想，等一下，你知道谁会那样做吗？Michael Scott会那样做。是的，他会。所以她说，在她提出这个想法之前，因为她有点担心这个点子太疯狂了，她研究了这个现象。她说有太多案例是人们因为GPS的指示而把车开下悬崖或开进水里的。
She said usually it was a case where like maybe there was a bridge somewhere. and it had been taken down and the GPS didn't know and it told you to drive across a bridge that didn't exist. But anyway, she brought it into the room and she pitched it and she showed all of her evidence for why this could really happen and it made it into the episode. Well, it's fantastic. And you guys, she is right because I Googled it as well. There are so many stories online of people driving their cars into things because the GPS told
她说通常情况是，可能某个地方有一座桥，它已经被拆除了，而GPS不知道，它指示你穿过一座不存在的桥。但不管怎样，她把这个想法带到了会议室，她提出了这个想法，并展示了所有证据证明这真的可能发生，于是它就出现在了这一集中。嗯，这太棒了。而且伙计们，她是正确的，因为我也谷歌了一下。网上有太多关于人们因为GPS指示而把车开进各种地方的故事。
them too. Here, of all of them that I read, and there were so many, I couldn't read them all. Here are two examples, just to show you, okay? Okay. Okay. In 2009, Robert Jones was using his navigation in West Yorkshire, England, and the road began to steepen and narrow, but it kept telling him to keep going. It kept insisting the path was the road, he later explained, so he trusted it. Jones only realized how wrong he was when his car bumped up against a thin wire fence just inches from a 100-foot drop. The car was taking him on the edge. Like the edge, there was no road. He managed to get out safely, but the car remained balanced on the edge. It took a recovery team nine hours to haul the car away. Oh my God. So this wasn't a road. It just was slowly, like it was like a road that
它们也是。在这里，在我读过的所有案例中，有太多了，我读不完。这里有两个例子，只是为了给你们展示一下，好吗？好的。好的。2009年，Robert Jones在英国西约克郡使用导航，道路开始变得陡峭和狭窄，但导航一直告诉他继续前进。他后来解释说，它一直坚持那条路就是正路，所以他相信了它。Jones直到他的车撞上了一个距离100英尺深渊仅几英寸的细铁丝网时，才意识到自己错得有多离谱。车把他带到了边缘。就像边缘，根本没有路。他设法安全逃脱，但车仍然平衡在边缘上。救援队花了九个小时才把车拖走。天哪。所以那根本不是路。它只是慢慢地，就像一条路，然后……
like narrowed into this, you know, hill. It was like a cliffside. Yes. And then here's this. In 2011, three women were visiting Bellevue, Washington. And they were out after midnight, and they were unable to find their hotel. So they asked GPS, right? That seems like a normal thing to do.
收窄成了这个，你知道，山坡。就像悬崖边。是的。然后还有这个。2011年，三名女性在华盛顿州贝尔维尤市游玩。她们在午夜后外出，找不到酒店。所以她们问了GPS，对吧？这看起来是很正常的事情。
GPS rerouted them and took them on what they thought was a road that would lead them to the highway. Instead, their SUV ended up sinking into deep water. The road turned out to be a boat launch. Oh, my gosh. Yes, and the water was a lake. All three managed to get out safely, but by the time the tow truck arrived, the SUV was completely submerged. Quote, from the, and this is the local fireman in Bellevue, Washington was quoted as saying this. We've seen sitcom parodies of something like this, but to actually see it is surprising.
GPS重新规划了路线，把她们带到了一条她们以为会通往高速公路的路上。结果，她们的SUV最终沉入了深水中。那条路原来是一个船只下水坡道。哦，天哪。是的，水是一个湖。三个人都设法安全逃脱，但当拖车到达时，SUV已经完全淹没了。引用，来自，这是华盛顿州贝尔维尤市的一位当地消防员说的话。我们见过类似这样的情景喜剧模仿，但亲眼看到它真是令人惊讶。
Oh, I'm sure they were referring to our show. I think so. You know, when Lee and I were first dating, we went to France. This was our first big trip together as a couple. Oh, that sounds so fun. Yes, and we drove through the French countryside and we rented a car, but the GPS was in French. We weren't thinking. Well, we've discussed, Angela, that I know a little bit of French.
哦，我敢肯定他们指的是我们的节目。我想也是。你知道，当Lee和我刚开始约会时，我们去了法国。这是我们作为情侣的第一次大旅行。哦，听起来真有趣。是的，我们开车穿过法国乡村，租了一辆车，但GPS是法语的。我们没多想。嗯，我们讨论过，Angela，我懂一点法语。
You know a handful of French. So I say to Lee, I'll translate it. This sounds like your first fight as a couple about to happen. Honey, I'll translate the navigation in a foreign country where you're driving and you've never driven here before. Well, the problem was that it would take me a second to realize what the directions were. And so there was this one turn where it would be like, turn a duat. and I would be like, turn right, turn right. But I was behind and we missed the turn.
你知道一点点法语。所以我对Lee说，我来翻译。这听起来像是你们作为情侣要发生的第一次争吵。亲爱的，我来翻译一个外语国家的导航，而你正在开车，而且你以前从没在这里开过车。嗯，问题在于我需要一秒钟才能反应过来方向是什么。所以有一次转弯，它会说，Turn a duat（向右转）。我会说，向右转，向右转。但我慢了，我们错过了那个转弯。
Yeah. So Lee did this huge circle around to get us back to this spot. And the person would be like, turn a do what? And I'd be like, right, right, right. It's turn right. And we missed that turn like four times because of my lag in translating properly. But it was more than, she wasn't just saying that. She was like lots of friends.
是的。所以Lee绕了一个大圈把我们带回那个点。然后那个人又会说，Turn a duat？我会说，右，右，右。是向右转。因为我翻译得不够及时，我们错过了那个转弯大概四次。但不仅仅是那样，她不只是在说那个。她就像有很多朋友。
and names of streets and somewhere embedded in there would be like Ternay Adwatt and I'd be like right I think right I feel like if it was you and I in the car and I'm driving
还有街道名称，中间夹杂着像Ternay Adwatt这样的词，我会说，右，我想是右。我觉得如果是在车里的是你和我，我在开车。
and you're doing that I'd be like the real southerner in me would come out like did she say Ardwat or not am I doing Ardwatt well you know Lee Angela and he is the most level person on the planet
而你在做那种事，我会像我内心深处的南方人一样爆发，比如，她到底说了Ardwat没有？我到底该不该做Ardwatt？嗯，你知道Lee，Angela，他是这个星球上最冷静的人。
Oh this man guys he is so well-tempered He's so good-natured, like, unshakable. Unshakeable. Well, after the fourth time of me missing Ternay Adwatt, he just goes, well, what the fuck? And I was like, oh, my God, I broke him. I broke me.
哦，伙计们，这个男人，他脾气太好了。他性格太好了，就像，不可动摇。不可动摇。嗯，在我第四次错过Ternay Adwatt之后，他只是说，好吧，这到底是什么鬼？我当时就想，哦，天哪，我把他逼疯了。我把自己逼疯了。
Was it like the first time you ever heard him curse? Yes. He was just, I was like, oh, my God. Does he still love me after France? But actually, we laughed. so hard about it for that very reason. Yeah, I was like, oh my God, I broke you in France. We laughed. Well, you didn't break them. The navigation lady broke them. Oh, my gosh. Guys, if you ever traveled to a foreign country and you're thinking you'll just rely on your GPS,
那是你第一次听到他骂人吗？是的。我当时就想，哦，天哪。他在法国之后还爱我吗？但实际上，我们因为这个原因笑得太厉害了。是的，我当时想，哦，天哪，我在法国把你逼疯了。我们笑了。嗯，你没有逼疯他。是导航小姐逼疯了他。哦，天哪。伙计们，如果你去外国旅行，并且认为你会只依赖你的GPS。
you have to request the language. Hot tip. Listen, I won't take us down that road, but Josh and I had a fight in Scotland where he had to be driving on the other side of the road trying to do a now for a roundabout. It was like, I can't roundabout. Anyway. Roundabouts are so great, though. They really are so smart. We should have roundabouts in this country. They are
你必须要求语言设置。小贴士。听着，我不会带我们走那条路，但Josh和我在苏格兰吵过一架，他必须在道路的另一侧开车，试图处理环岛。就像，我无法处理环岛。不管怎样。环岛真的很棒。它们确实很聪明。我们这个国家应该有环岛。它们是。
wonderful inventions. They're overwhelming at first because they are very foreign to us as American drivers, but truly they are a wonderful way to control the flow of traffic. I feel myself
美妙的发明。它们起初让人不知所措，因为作为美国司机，它们对我们来说非常陌生，但它们确实是控制交通流的绝佳方式。我感觉自己。
needing to deep dive on the history of roundabout. Deep dive, it probably goes back to the Romans or something, but doing a roundabout, driving on the opposite side of the road and exiting the opposite way that you've never exited is a recipe for maybe one of your first big fights in a car, just saying. Well, my pet peeve in America is that when we do have roundabouts, we put stop signs in them, which is not the point of a roundabout. Well, that's not how you do it. We're doing it wrong. Anyway. Okay. Well, guys, they do get out of the lake. they're soaking wet and their big takeaway from this moment
需要深入研究环岛的历史。深入研究，它可能追溯到罗马人什么的，但在环岛行驶，在道路的另一侧开车，并以你从未走过的方式出口，这可能是你在车里发生第一次大争吵的导火索，我只是说说而已。嗯，我在美国的烦恼是，当我们确实有环岛时，我们在里面放了停车标志，这根本不是环岛的意义所在。嗯，那不是你应该做的方式。我们做错了。不管怎样。好吧。嗯，伙计们，他们确实从湖里出来了。他们浑身湿透，他们从这一刻得到的最大收获。
the thing that they feel determined to do is to walk back to the previous client's office and reclaim their gift basket. Michael says they're going to take a stand. Also, Dwight's phone works. His flip phone. Yeah, old tech alert.
他们决心要做的事情是走回上一个客户的办公室，拿回他们的礼品篮。Michael说他们要表明立场。还有，Dwight的手机能用。他的翻盖手机。是的，老科技警报。
What I didn't understand about this was why they couldn't just take a cab. They have to walk. Yeah, I don't know. I don't know, because Dwight's phone does work. But Michael's like, no, we're walking. Well, back at the office, Ryan is reviewing some of Pam's sketches for the new Dunder Mifflin Infinity logo, which, by the way, I thought were great. Yeah, she did a great job.
我不明白的是为什么他们不能直接打车。他们必须走路。是的，我不知道。我不知道，因为Dwight的手机确实能用。但Michael说，不，我们要走路。嗯，回到办公室，Ryan正在审查Pam为新的Dunder Mifflin Infinity标志设计的一些草图，顺便说一下，我觉得那些草图很棒。是的，她做得很好。
But that's not what really Ryan was there to talk about. No, he wasn't really getting her sketches. He just wants to take her out to dinner and he was trying to be sneaky. Yeah. Ugh. Well, she turns him down, and this is when she informs him that she is dating Jim. He's like, no way. Yeah.
但那并不是Ryan去那里的真正目的。不，他并不是真的在看她的草图。他只是想带她出去吃晚饭，他在试图耍花招。是的。呃。嗯，她拒绝了他，这时她告诉他她正在和Jim约会。他说，不可能。是的。
Ryan cannot get over the fact that both Karen and Pam have dated Jim and not him. Yeah. Well, Michael and Dwight make it back to this law firm. I loved this scene so much. I watched it three times. It's so good. I mean, they walk in and they look horrible. They've been in a lake and they've walked in wet clothes.
Ryan无法接受Karen和Pam都和Jim约会过，而不是和他约会的事实。是的。嗯，Michael和Dwight回到了那家律师事务所。我太喜欢这个场景了。我看了三遍。太棒了。我的意思是，他们走进去，看起来糟透了。他们掉进湖里，穿着湿衣服走进来。
Yep. And I mean, Michael seems unhinged. Steve's performance is so good here. It is rooted in so much truth and hurt and anger. Disappointment. It is so good. He demands their gift basket back. When the guy finally brings the gift.
是的。我的意思是，Michael看起来精神崩溃了。Steve在这里的表演太棒了。它植根于太多的真实、伤害和愤怒。失望。太棒了。他要求拿回他们的礼品篮。当那个人终于把礼品篮拿出来时。
gift basket out, Michael notices that something is missing. The turtles. The turtles. And he loses his shataki. Poor Aaron. Aaron never saw this moment coming. He's like, Oh, that turtle!
Michael注意到少了东西。乌龟。乌龟。然后他彻底失控了。可怜的Aaron。Aaron从没预料到这一刻。他当时想，哦，那只乌龟！
Yeah. He loses his mind over these turtles. And Aaron is like, I ate them. They were mine. This gift basket was mine for a minute. it. So I ate things from it. But Dwight is like, we'll bill you for it. Oh, my gosh. It's incredible stuff. They just did that thing where they might have had a chance of getting him back. And then they just burned it to the ground. Yeah. Yeah. Well, they come back to the office. They storm in. Michael
是的。他因为这些乌龟而失去了理智。Aaron说，我吃了它们。它们是我的。这个礼品篮有一分钟是我的。所以我吃了里面的东西。但Dwight说，我们会给你开账单的。哦，天哪。这真是太不可思议了。他们刚刚做了一件本来还有机会挽回的事情。然后他们就把它彻底搞砸了。是的。是的。嗯，他们回到办公室。他们冲了进去。Michael。
proclaims that this office will no longer be using any new technology of any kind because he drove his car into a Lake. An effing lake. Well, Oscar is like, you did what? And he is like, I drove my car into an effing lake. And they bleep it out. And this was rare. We did not do a lot of bleeping on our show. But every once in a while, man, it's just funnier this way. It's just funnier this way. Yeah. He also wants everybody to know that unlike technology, gift baskets never endangered anybody's lives.
宣称这个办公室将不再使用任何形式的新技术，因为他把车开进了一个湖里。一个该死的湖。嗯，Oscar说，你做了什么？他说，我把车开进了一个该死的湖。他们把它消音了。这很少见。我们的节目里没有做太多的消音。但偶尔，伙计，这样反而更好笑。这样反而更好笑。是的。他还想让每个人都知道，与技术不同，礼品篮从未危及任何人的生命。
and he basically declares himself triumphant. Yes, he does. And there's a very big Angela Martin eye roll at 40 minutes, 43 seconds, as Michael declares himself the winner. But he doesn't just declare himself the winner. This is what he says. To Ryan, his new boss, he says, game set match, point Scott, game over, end of game. And then he tries one more, but he can't think of it, so then he just walks into his office. it's so good it is so good
他基本上宣布自己取得了胜利。是的，他确实这么做了。在40分43秒时，有一个非常大的Angela Martin翻白眼，当时Michael宣布自己是赢家。但他不仅仅宣布自己是赢家。他是这么说的。对他的新老板Ryan，他说，比赛结束，Scott得分，游戏结束，游戏终结。然后他想再试一次，但他想不出来，所以他就走进了他的办公室。太棒了，太棒了。
Michael ends it all with a final talking head and we see all of us eating from the gift basket in the conference room I remember shooting that scene remember yeah we shot the scene earlier where we were looking at all the things and I remembered I can't wait until we do the scene where I get to eat all this I was not in the conference room
Michael以最后的采访结束了这一切，我们看到我们所有人都在会议室里吃礼品篮里的东西。我记得拍摄那个场景。记得，是的，我们早些时候拍摄了那个场景，我们看着所有的东西，我记得我等不及要拍我们吃掉所有这些东西的场景了。我当时不在会议室。
Angela's having none of it yeah it's too bad because they were some good There was some good stuff. I know. I remember you guys were actually excited in real life to open up those packages. And then ultimately we end the episode with a Ryan talking head. He's still gloating about his new schmancy life. He says, you know, he's not saying he had a meteoric rise, but, you know, but I guess he did.
Angela对此一点也不感兴趣。是的，太可惜了，因为它们是一些好的。有一些好东西。我知道。我记得你们在现实生活中确实很兴奋能打开那些包装。最终我们以Ryan的采访结束了这一集。他还在为他那奢华的新生活沾沾自喜。他说，你知道，他不是说他经历了飞速的崛起，但是，你知道，但我猜他确实经历了。
And that his haircut was $200. He's just being such a tool. And, lady, there are some great extra. and the deleted scenes of Ryan bragging about New York, he has a whole thing with Jim about like, well, you know, in New York, and Jim's like, yeah, I actually, I've been there and he's like, no, no, no, but it's different. You've got to live there. Like, you don't, you can't really understand what I'm talking about because you haven't lived there. So, you know, sorry. Yeah. But anyway, they're really funny. That's too bad. I really loved the scene
而且他的理发花了200美元。他真是个混蛋。而且，女士，有一些很棒的额外内容。在Ryan吹嘘纽约的删减片段中，他和Jim有一整段对话，比如，嗯，你知道，在纽约，Jim说，是的，其实，我去过那里，他说，不，不，不，但那是不一样的。你必须住在那里。就像，你不能真正理解我在说什么，因为你没住在那里。所以，你知道，抱歉。是的。但不管怎样，它们真的很有趣。太可惜了。我真的很喜欢那个场景。
between him and Jim. He just would not let it go. Well, that's it, guys. That finishes out Dunder Mifflin Infinity. Dunder Mifflin Infinity. And up next, Jenna, is what? Lanch party? Lunch party. Launch party. Kevin. Well, it's a party. Launch party. All right, guys. We'll see you next week. See you next week. Have a great one. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwolf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jorkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Molly Nugent.
他和Jim之间的对话。他就是不肯放过。嗯，就是这样，伙计们。Dunder Mifflin Infinity结束了。Dunder Mifflin Infinity。接下来，Jenna，是什么？发布会？午餐派对。发布会。Kevin。嗯，这是一个派对。发布会。好了，伙计们。我们下周见。下周见。祝你们过得愉快。感谢收听Office Ladies的第二杯。本集最初是与Earwolf合作创作的。Office Ladies是Odyssey的节目，由Jenna Fisher和Angela Kinsey制作。我们的执行制片人是Cassie Jorkins，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是Molly Nugent。
Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Thank you. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是Leah Reese Dennis。Office Ladies由Bill Schultz混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是Creed Bratton的Rubber Tree。谢谢。谢谢。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。